kühl
basculer mathieu
ouais mais la bascule et fait mathieu
et tu la patrie l'a pas sentie elle
s'est faite et aux places étant c'est
vrai c'est basculer
à temps par contre on entend à temps on
en entend mathiot pas est ce qu'on
entend mathieu sur la bascule ou pas
oui on t'entend mathieu sur la bascule
avait pas vraiment basculé en fait
jusqu'à maintenant dernières journées de
souffrance
oh ben non alors on souffre plus un
caruana fil rouge
26 des trucs intéressants
à un petit rapport à dieu boeuf ou bien
il ya déjà deux berlin a
je pense qu'on se met sur une premier
vers une première berlin fab sais pas ce
que tu en penses on aime bien les
berlinoise généralement ils ricci ricci
veut
héritier qui va il est un peu plus mais
aussi il ya plus les écrans non un bug
non ouais mais ça y est on récupère
caruana fierro farrugia est ce qu'ils
vont jouer ou pas oui oui
il ya eu la balance il ne sait plus
belles très petit pas
ils firent haut qui joue le berlin je
serais tenté de jouer la finale
[Rires]
c'est vrai oui vivace avec le choix
pratique de caruana mais bon on voyait
une idée il va remettre 100 km à 5 mai
à huîtres c'est qu'il a déjà joué dans
la semaine
qui change les amteurs main monde il
n'est pas ça peut paraître partir sur
une île déjà ça
non pas du tout que si
ça fera peut-être nul mais
je connais pas deux nuls tempo là dessus
non je pense à jouer partout un
puce la démarche où il avait perdu
l'année on devrait donc c'est pas
illogique de lui jouer
ouais mais après il s'en fout
complètement de la perdre
ouais mais il a dit qu'il serait content
de finir invaincus cette fois c'est à la
fois il l'a perdu
en plus 12 heures franchement jamais
compris pourquoi la la journaliste qui
fait des photos via un pyjama en pilou
mais en plus elle est très gentil
mignonne mais justesse mais en pyjama à
chaque fois
très sympa pour les joueurs
peut-être que ça lui plaît quoi cette
confortable et des jeunes gens deux
c'est bien les pyjamas
mais là aux olympiades et omis dress
code sequans code alors
t'as pas l'euro jean roux jean georges
tron par le patin
et ses copains c'est pas mal je ne sais
pas a lâché jean moi je mets beaucoup de
jeunes beaucoup
[Musique]
refaire garde robe
normalement tu dois avoir une veste
cinquante mille degrés quoi ça ouais
mais je pense qu'on va pas sortir de
l'hôtel climatisé
et en cas de co vite il se passe quoi
déjà pour rentrer au pays favorite est
convient tout en admettant que tu
attrapes le coc vie de là bas
je pense que tu es viré du tournoi était
pour tout le monde contacts mais je la
lia déteste les east obligatoire ou
plutôt tout est un peu comme dix alliés
à 10 écornée par rapport aux longs
garros en fait personne ce test pour
être bien sûr de parader
dans les tôles un déchet quand j'avais
fait ces tests obligatoires journée de
repos et avant le premier jour c'était
il ya eu il ya pas si longtemps je peux
d'europe et non les échecs font un tsa
ces soirées est visible lundi ils ont
ils sont assez sérieux là dessus à la
frontière aucun
bon
complexe albert noaa
âgées expliqué l'autre jour que quand tu
fais qu'aller 17 j'aimerais mieux que
ton fou son no 6 ouais
mais là il est multi 1 17 direct
sa prépa mais c'est quand même étonnant
et la velle temps de faire autre chose
alors qu'ils le font des six tu fais
g4 après il a que faire là t'as pas de
tout ce que tu es ce que tu as continué
à faire des prépas mind quand même quand
est dernier du tournoi
c'est pour ça que va de la capote
carbone affirme
oui je vais peut-être encore un peu la
deuxième place quand même fabiano je ne
serai pas pour faire nul tu sais qu'un
nul tu fais rien ouais
je combats peut-être qu'il en a
tellement en fait que assez sa série
world est en fait s'il n'a pas
d'échéance enfin il est quoi ils et les
olympiades en un mois ouais ok
d'ailleurs c'est les olympiades j'ai été
étonné mais la norvège tête de série
numéro quatre parce je crois qu'ils ont
un mec qui leur montrent la personne
moyenne c'est quoi c'est que les quatre
premiers
ces cachots 5e et tu penses que magnus
il est super bien payé pour aller jouer
les olympiades j'étais un peu étonnée
via la france y va parce qu'il veut
défendre les cours il va tout le temps
non défendre les couleurs de béliveau
doit tout le temps mais il va souvent en
fait il s'entend très bien avec
kristensen ils s'entendent bien avec le
dernier chiffre s'entend bien avec lui
je les ai même vu avec mais il s'entend
bien avec les joueurs va t'il un certain
jacques taris il faut faire du sport il
joue quand il veut il kiffe l'ambiance
il fallait bien mis de la partie mais
c'est un sujet qui la joue souvent les
vous souvent les olympiques à soi même
et il aime bien vite il
énoncé quant à la fois qu'on ait une
autre équipe max du coup bas l'an
dernier
2014 peut être
ça remonte aussi loin
et les dernières quand on a failli feng
a failli gagner quand on a perdu la
russie à la dernière on était pas max
pas tout à fait
attendre l'histoire de la russie s'était
séquence de 2018 ouais je pense de
plusieurs fois peut-être que 2018 on
n'était pas trop mal
et les filles qui partent 6e et l'eau le
meilleur c'est le changement
d'entraîneur probablement
elles ont progressé oui mais enfin on
s'est débarrassé il ya une chose faire
progresser mais on est une autorisation
mais on a déjà été à peu près ça mais là
il fait juste qui manque la russie et la
chine
ça change de trois trucs
d'oran m et nous nous cette année en
équipe max en mixte on pouvait vraiment
gagné
on aurait vraiment été enfin
enfin pour les filles pas de russie pas
de chine c'est quasiment deux équipes
intouchable quoi
ça va juste ça décale un peu coincés on
a failli accrocher la russie une fois je
prends
les attaquerons nature perdu à la fin
mais de très peu on a fait gagner une
année sociale battu gunino
non la chine c'est durant la chine se
dit des fois ils jouent eye il n'ya une
lame code il joue avec we fans comme hey
jude en plus non ouais ouais
mondiale et championne du monde quoi
this is it est acquis non et c'est là où
elle avait perdu où il fane contre la la
police
de ce noir et rouge sont peut-être
plus derrière des 3 et 4 s'est pas non
plus des manches bas cd on les connaît
pas mais en 2005 où
tu ne tu nous feras un petit un petit
bloc de là-bas ou pas
je sais pas ce que c'est un socle ne
vais pas être fini avec la caméra et des
petites capsules pour twitter on peut se
faire des trucs avec maso montrer un peu
l'ambiance sur place si vous n'avez pas
trop chaud bah c'est vrai est-ce qu'il
ya le danger qui pèse en coin ses
reportages sur les rives du gange c'est
dans l'est j'avoue j'ai pas très
familiers
il fait ici convient quelle température
genre aujourd'hui je vais les tchèques
pas tant que ça séoul est tracé et
chennai non c'est l'ancienne madras 53
sa bombe avait tué le même temps qu ici
et je il pleut beaucoup oui mais enfin
tant mieux on a été très heureux qui
pleuvent la température august
ça c'est le pire et le taux depuis qui
est pénible
et l'humidité quoi ça à temps il fait
entre 35 et 25 et à cannes il fait
combien même période à meyreuil comparé
l'humidité la pile le jour de plus
l'humidité il fait ça ici faibles
températures j'arrive pas à trouver
mais la france est à ces
jeux j'allais au japon jeudi à la hong
kong aux philippines j'ai vu des trucs
humide donc pas hyper diable tu sais pas
qui a décollé
ouais c'est tu sors du métro
from une douche bien il fait 4 degrés de
plus qu'ici bon
c'est pas les mêmes quatre
est alors oui c'est vrai mais ici aussi
c'est chaleur humide un non
moins humide quoi
et on regarde les coûts d'un il ya eu la
même ouverture dans le rapporte radjabov
oui la guyane c'est vrai que cela mine
la
vague et 17 mai
bah oui la milf ont eu six d'abord
et au rock food et 6 qui avait trop ce
qu'elle des deux fois ci soit la fois
aussi c'est pas moi le coup le plus
logique mais vous m'expliquer que 33
mois j'ai vécu les endroits qu'ils aient
moins 40 de l'hiver coiffe à -47
variable aussi
j'ai vécu tous les ans enfin ça va je
suis encore en vie quoi md millions des
centaines de millions de personnes qui
vivent mais bon ça va
en inde et je crois qu'il ya du nombre
sinon oui mais je l'aï 10 comme +33
humides en mode c'est pas comme c'est à
dire des planètes où tu as faim enfin
c'est chiant je dis pas le contraire
mais bon
quand tu as fait moins 42 fussent 33 tu
sais ma femme
oui je donnerai pas l'air mais guère
impressionnant qu'enfin
un des pires que j'ai fait ces quarante
et quelques dans mon appart sont un clin
d'oeil mais c'est hyper chiant mais
33 minutes c'est quand il s'était plus
qu'à rentrer en france
oui non mais c'est pas agréable mais le
taux d'humidité de bah
en fait je ne suis jamais allée jean
saint mais je me souviens genre la coupe
du monde 2002 en corée japon je sais que
tous les commentateurs m taux d'humidité
machin
voilà le rugby france japon il est taux
d'humidité
90210 % je crois et je crois qu'ils
aient 33,34 bon les mecs ont quand même
fait 90 de rugby enfin bref
en plein air quoi plein soleil plein air
sont là convions donc à la fin c'était
brésil allemagne la finale s'était pas
non plus n'importe quoi en 2002 mais
c'est sûr que c'est très désagréable
jeudi par l' inverse mais je veux juste
dire que
[Musique]
fait je pensais qu'ils aient 43,40 fait
entre 43 et 45 et là
ok je pense c'est difficilement autonome
tenable ouais mais +33 +35 même si c'est
très humide fin ok c'est très
désagréable mais pour toucher de la clim
qua non mais c'est pas comme quand tu as
fait a pas longtemps là je pars à damas
+52 ou un truc comme ça non il y avait
un truc là c'est tout le pakistan
chettouh cet avis faisait très chaud au
pakistan if the hitcher de ouf mais gère
50 kw à
ses patients malades le pakistan avait
il dit ignorer les coûts de faire une
prépa avec aucun avantage et 27 jours
c'est génial j'adore ça en fait
cette icône l'ouverture c'est ce truc
c'est génial ça va être s'il est tous
contents il a toujours tempo
donc on traduit quoi ouais mais il avait
gagné donc un contrat dit non elle est
perdue en vain coutlée blanco non non
non pas contre eux a dit le jour quand
il fait 30 contes dauda 25 août je le
sais rien
mais il a gagné
meding près je sais pas quel point elle
est bien préparée s'il n'a pas de
seconde en sur place était pas prévu de
jouer avant il ya un mois quoi donc je
sais pas
peut-être qu'ils cliquent juste
parcours d'étudiant 2002 mais je sais
pas c'était pas fait une haie contre la
corée sur des décisions arbitrage
injuste et c'était prix des rouges des
trucs la corée du sud froid qui est
vraiment un truc de
cirque l'arbitrage s'en mêle ses
différentes du climat qu'en fait on pour
le climat
mais la corée jouais bien je vais pas
mal dans ledit exact voilà
la moins chère retrouvez la différence
de température entre chennai et cannes
qui furent paris sa a trouvé ça me
turlupine en fait maintenant
pour aller tester quoi passer une
semaine à chennai avoir ressenti
c'est toi qui va pouvoir nous dire ouais
oui j'ai vécu à cal donc
non mais c'est sûr que c'est chiant
après
mais bon tu vois et ce qui fait plus
chaud qu'à marrakech jusqu'à marrakech
franchement ça doit être fait très chaud
en été moi j'ai joué à chefchaouen l'été
où
il fait combien chefs tchaman il fait
chaud il fait vraiment chaud je sais pas
on peut la regarder la chef charles
météo
même maintenant
maintenant aujourd'hui
ouais ouais il fait comme ici quoi
aujourd'hui
c'est que saint-affrique il peut faire
choix aussi comme tu as la montagne
chefchaouen
c'est parce que sa femme était à la
montagne
fait de températures assez en altitude
on nous dit un mec a vécu un en guyane
il dit que 32 à kourou c'est pire que 40
à bordeaux alors qu'aqmi chkil connu 54
à marrakech
c'est comme ça quoi non mais avec moi je
m'attends afrique slim
tu sors jamais tout
et dans un bel hôtel
en fait ne sait pas quand notre hôtel
on
n'a pas nos visas on n'a pas la vie ta
tion delà du tournoi en coop et moi j'ai
voulu faire mon visa tout seul mais il
faut chaque pas que fera la visant c'est
un visa il fait tout ça comme pour les
états unis j'imagine assez vite fait
tout ça non mais je sais pas quand
indirecte dans notre grande ce qui est
chiant avec les visas c'est que tu peux
être refusée à l'aéroport
mais en fait suite à l'invitation du
tournoi non ça sera connu il y aura même
une personne qui arrive oui mais bon
c'est que j'ai en appel invitation mais
ils ont la demande est apparu et le teil
langage c par rapport à la place de la
dernière olympiade nessakh maso hyper
confiant qu'on soit dans le meilleur
hôtel de la ville de sheraton les
olympiades stand 2020 du coup est en
ligne mais par exemple tu crois
sincèrement que la norvège va peut être
offert à tous
ouais mais bon
je me souviens oui [ __ ] à tromsø à oui
on avait chez vous aviez changé de tels
les filles on avait dit qu'on restait
bon ok mais peu importe on n'était pas
trop mal noté au centre dans tous les
cas mais il ya des équipes près des bus
pendant une heure avant de venir jouer
c'était à perpète à 50 km c'était
dégueulasse
je sais plus mais c'est vrai que l'hôtel
on avait déménagé vite et bien quand
même sur le toit et où j'étais content
moi j'étais à l'autre
à quelqu'un aller en turquie à l'époque
il y avait un petit pic à 53 mais quand
il fait cette température là tu me rends
combien de temps dehors on l'a fait il
veut pas devoir de dire non mais tu vois
tu vas pas me la retire de tempo non
plus l'inversé genre une heure ces
genres 15 minutes ces genres 3h sais pas
je pense ça va pas ça va l'acia si tu
bois jamais et que tu cours bon
peut-être comment ça s'est passé mais si
tu marches qui cherchait un peu l'ombre
qui fin ça
bon ok bah je vais vous laisser les
partis sont pas ou feint et michael tu
peux pas à nous dire ça là encore j ça
les gens disent on s'est vraiment très
grave qui n'est pas intéressé par les
échecs si même toi t'es pas intéressé
par les échecs mathieu salle à la plus
intéressante c'est oda et on peu déçu
ballon est la plus intéressante pas te
laisser tranquille et au pire tu peux
repasser dans un vent si tu veux
oui au moins voilà ça joue c'est vrai
mais bon ça a vraiment plus aucun
intérêt sportif provient des sportifs
mais bon ça joue bien la joue bien on
verra après dépôt il peut sur bouton
vers 17
dans le 17 c'était le nouveau coup à
deux carreaux noir
et en fait il s'était arrêté de jouer et
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
c'était là on l'avait fait une vidéo
avec vlad que sur ce coup là la liste
est très fin ouais et lycées a égalisé
tout de suite y ait plus rien à
connaître mes amants ils sont ratés de
jouer ça il ya plein de partis qu'on
voit où ils font pas d'âme 17
non ça va je sais quoi
et l'essai ne serait pas de se rappeler
à la caméra
attendu
un cousin du coup on a pensé peu des
trois
parce que nous sommes bonne diagonale
ouais mais le fou il est un peu chiant
parce que si tu fais c4 après trois
trous avec des trous
si tu fais rien enfin jacqueline ici si
tu fais c'est roi lui même peut-être
parce qu'il veut c'est rohff des 3 kg 3
h 4
par la batterie au pire ou kg 5 qui part
j'aime mieux kg 3
c'est l'heure du thé
n'est pas ça doit être difficile
psychologiquement à jouer cette partie
c'est la 1ère fois il avait turbo perdu
way too soon compliqué grèce de l'autre
renault nissan plus souvent très près
pape ça ne sert plus à rien
tu dois complètement être en
décompression et est ce que tu penses
que carrasset lille a dit j accepte de
joël si dans le contrat ses écrits une
épaule ne peux pas je l'appelais trust
mais
moi ça me paraît bizarre comme la fille
tu vois c'est à ce niveau là on en
parlait ce matin avec fable que c'est
pas une
une organisation puissante parce que tu
vois wimbledon qui est le tournoi
principal au tennis c'est genre le plus
gros tournoi de l'année ces genres le
temple ils ont fait un truc qui va à
l'encontre de la de l'atp de la tennis
association de leurs fidèles leur fille
d'à e et en fait ils sont immédiatement
fait dégager de détournant en fait ça
compte pas pour le classement compte pas
pour le classement ils sont dégagés un
stand de l'atp et j'imagine que tu
viendrais pour négocier de changer avant
la finale le nombre de sept ou le format
du match avant la finale de n'importe
quel tournoi atp en fait on débat je
passe te veux des gars je pense que tu
serais même dégager enfin rien que le
fait d'en parler officiellement si nadal
parle officiellement avant la finale de
roland mais je ne vais peut-être pas
joué si si c'est le même format je pense
qu'en fait il va se prendre une
commission d'éthique 1 face à peut être
nadal se battre federer c'est peut-être
qu'ils savent eux c'est ça des gâches
instantanément je pense voilà enfin
j'veux dire quand ces jo gook avait
envoyé une balle comme ça il a dégagé de
l'us open quand il a su faire le vaccin
on dégage au lendemain guerrier et puis
bah même là tu vois le match 6 passes
querios ils sont plus de dix mille et
4000 livres dollars d'amendé oui la
discussion il a répondu lol ouais mais
la discussion c'est de savoir s'il
aurait dû juste dégager de citi passe
quand même peut-être que si ça avait été
un tournoi atp il aurait été dégagée
d'ailleurs par un superviseur atp donc
moi j'ai toujours pensé que
l'institution il doit être plus forte
que les joueurs avec les tournois et la
celle inverse en fait ce puits autres se
pliait pas ils sont pas fort ouais c'est
ça ils sont très faibles c'est horrible
enflammé en plus en période d'élection
je pense seul pierre
- ouais parce que normalement en fait il
devrait choisir était venu discuter tu
fais une atteinte à l'image de la fille
d du championnat du monde déjà
commission d'éthique juste comme ça pour
commencer bon après commission d'éthique
qui va pas de punir mais juste pour
rappeler les bases et ici tu continues
ben en fait c'est terminé quoi faire
tant pis pour toi non mais ce qu'ils
auraient dû demander toute façon de
manière claire et nette avant le tour
des candidats que la pollution soit
clarifiée pas soit la deuxième place
joue pour quelque chose soit joue pas
mais on peut pas ne pas savoir ça change
beaucoup de choses en fait bah ça change
la façon de cartonnage exactement un
mois il a fait des eaux l'insee 0,5 sur
quatre si jamais ils savaient que
deuxièmes se qualifient il va pas de
faire ça enfin ça c'est le même deuxième
pas le premier pour moi il ya champagne
ou pas bah oui c'est normal aussi je
crois oui c'est normal c'est normal et
puis on repart sur un autre cycle et il
aura un match ou bien mais un peu je
trouve que ça protège la fidh parce que
du coup tout le monde en veut encore
moins à carson
c'est vrai aussi est quelqu'un qui lit
bas il fait ce qu'il veut magnus il veut
pas jouer il joue pas mais ça c'est sûr
j'avais juste en fait tu peux pas
imposer des conditions en cours de route
n'ont pas joué c'est juste une idée de
base en fait la faute à pas choisir un
qui dit par contre pour le prochain
cycle ça serait bien qu'on rediscute et
que si si ça soit fait mais ça c'est une
autre histoire ça c'est très bien
d'ailleurs je pense mais mais là pour
celui là la cc dont six mois les joueurs
ont déjà participé au cycle avec une
cadence comme ça machin pas né avec son
clair sur la plage changer la règle bien
au delà de ça le juste prix le champion
du monde il a déjà de tels privilèges
que c'est encore en demander
mais bon pour moi karlsson n'est pas du
tout à blâmer là-dessus enfin je le
blâme absolument pas assez c'est à la
fidh de
de se montrer forte en fait
je
sont pas très fort
ouais c'est dommage quand ils sont
obligés de là
et je soupçonne que ce soit là une des
lignes importantes comme de celle ci
parce que
l'epo il réfléchit et on voit qu'ils
essaient de se rappeler ça aurait
d'ailleurs à des subtilités tu as un
truc pour bien tenir en force ouais si
tu fais pas ce que vous faites c'est un
bon choix pour les blancs quand tu y
réfléchis tu as toutes les pièces
puisse paraître of symétrique ben moi
j'ai toujours bien aimé avoir un pur 9,5
pour mes pièces qui tourne autour
après il ya je vois pas de plan non plus
direct
[Musique]
ça ses responsables
et art tranquille et voit son petit café
après faut dire que comme dirait vlad
c'est probablement pas sa ligne de
première importance ouais bon niveau
je pense que là il a tout donné sur sa
petrov qui joue que la petrov et il va
retravailler si l'un au chômage fin du
monde donc
il n'a pas des chiens si je peux les
olympiens belge rien je veux rien pas de
jackman qui lui file un petit machin
mais c'est pas très grave non là je
pense vraiment qu'ils jouent au moins un
truc important parce que là il connaît
encore un
je vais vous envoyer à vous les partis
de toutes les parties que j'ai commenté
de la semaine si vous pouvez m'envoyer
celle que j'ai pas bon non nous avons
sera pas du même niveau mais oui mais je
veux avoir un fichier goal adorateurs
d'agathois
on sera vraiment très très ferme à tuer
les analystes
épouses des années les deux sévres
l'accent de les voir au robot il a cette
année
je pense que tout le monde a envie de
rentrer quand même à la maison la maison
enfin c'est vrai que 12 ans on aurait pu
penser qu'il a expédié la partie c'est
dire quand même ce qu'il a fait
oui d'audace elle pas été une énigme de
la semaine je les trouvais très très
bizarre
et qu'on sait solide genre peut-être
cinq nuls les cinq premières rondes puis
s'est mis à perdre il a quand même battu
caruana s'améliore pas faire b4 c'est
incroyable vous avez des cinq chars et
ça marche pas du tout non il ya plein de
manières de vue il faut des six ya des
six dames f3 et des progressistes au
cifa 6 à 3 réfute les chocottes
non mais même après il faut que tu as
fait le con de pas faire reprendre et
quand même pas repayer c5 qui aidé cette
fois c'est vraiment un écueil c5 ça fait
nul suffit quel point d'être mais oui
mais tu es la structure sert d'abri oui
oui c'est fou les faits l'affairé des
scènes vraiment tempo en plus cette
seconde je me suis fait un actif de
regarder le temps jouait pour les coûts
j'ai trouvé ça assez intéressant pour
voir comment les gens gérer leur temps
et tout mais elle tient d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant la vie de nakache ouest
avait tué son petit récap chaque jour
non j'ai regardé l'interview juskila
devient en fait juste voilà quand ils
jouent food et 6 etc en
fait il y aurait en fait d'où da il
secouer la tête sauvée qui n'était pas
bien et que c'est hyper dur de te
remettre en selle dont tu viens de faire
le con tu sais ce que j'ai dit devenant
à vélo a résumé je réclame une écoute et
que en fait ils jouaient exprès vite
après dakar peut-être qu'il savait que
ses parts sans les murs coup leur
bassiste ou mais qu' il voulait pas
laisser le temps de se remettre les
idées en place et que et qu'en fait ils
voyaient avec nokia n avait des gens
même la ligne là où il ya deux pièces
pour la toile de fond 5 tours 17 machin
qu'il doit y avoir un truc moi je trouve
que rien mais ça risque quand tu vois
les pièces du diois de faire un truc et
il s'est pas pris la tête il a juste
envoyé des coups et duda il a implosé
live sur la seconde
donc il a joué de manière très pratique
quand on revient il à un voyage 4 il
envisage quatre assez vite un air
toujours
en respect les parties leur vie
et départ cours
depuis longtemps en train de regarder
une partie de mousse art 2022 on drague
nef ouais il avait joué cavalier fin
avant rock
moi donc c'est pas exactement pareil
rock ya qu une partie c'est hector actor
bon ça va pas de près par hector il
n'avait pas joué neuf tours 1 en fait
c'est tout est nouveau mesdames 17 en
fait c'est calme rare parce qu'il ya 27
parties merveille là ils ont toujours su
cette variante
au bout du doigt il clique c'est ça que
firent ou à je le sois plusieurs fois
avec les blancs le jeu mais joe dante
c'est ouais il nous faut aussi du goût
mais aux grands suisses n'ont
giroud abbas sauf et n'a hier je pensais
du grand suisse mais ouais mais c'est le
départ du comté kevin est en fait de me
poser la question c'est quoi le poids de
nos dames 17 g/t au courage mais en
pratique
il a joué en force
ouais mais j'ai regardé le cas et décès
de l'allemand en a parlé entre nous ça
égalise pas complètement en forçant
quelque a réalisé 7 sur la
jetant mes mots
à moi j'ai beaucoup à ce qu'il y ait des
7 à 6 6 et égalise en force et sur un
peu trompe pas assez c'est pas bête mais
c'est pas il ajoute qu on s'éclate fossé
de céder et à sa clique à fond du coup
des cadres va arriver
il veut il faut bien sûr une des quatre
mois
c'est le premier coup de l'ordi assez
génial à 5 baky koné 1 ou c'est moi je
m'attendais à des 4 mais la phase 5 se
lever
alors ça c'est vraiment une position
qu'il a étudiée pour les remonter sur
sa tête qui va préparer autre chose que
la petrov contre magnus ça veut dire
qu'il dit magnus a aussi et que tout le
monde sait ça a été une erreur non je la
garde enfin il faut qu'ils renforcent
mais
en plus il va gagner de l'expérience à
force de la jouer
mais en fait un truc j'ai pas compris
moi les chambres ont toujours peur ck
one shock s'arrêter là jouer alors ça va
super bien
il avait gagné les candidats en 2018 en
fin 2007 pour se qualifier contre magnus
il n'en perd pas une quand il jouait les
tournois ça se passait super bien fait
il faisait chier tout le monde axa
petrov il finit mal championnats du
monde et des îles à joue plus jamais
quoi je crois que ça le fait chier il a
bien changé mais après il a eu la
reconquête lui a rapporté quand même pas
mal de villes à avoir changé et
maintenant il fait sens relationnel
ouvert tous moins bien
mais je vous dis enfin on vas tu
comprends bien qu'il eût changé c'est un
bal points mais de carrément jeté à la
poubelle le truc battu pour l envoyer
une fois sur cinq coups sûrs en cinq ans
fait mais sur le profil de l'adversaire
ou
ses juges j'ai pas mes marquillies mais
mon jeu une fois peut-être une fois
allez on va dire
mais il est malade
et avait aussi que ce n'est pas dit
qu'ils avaient implosé parce qu'il avait
trop travailler avant le championnat du
monde et c'est j ai pensé et qui pouvait
juste plus voir un échiquier en fait à
partir d'un moment donné ça le faisait
trop chier en fait son cerveau refusé
même de réfléchir aux échecs mais je
veux tellement de comprendre moi ça
m'arrive aussi mais là c'est bien sa
valeur
cette expérience là l île c'est son
seuil de tolérance au travail et donc il
va peut-être pas faire quatre mois
non-stop mais que deux ou trois gardes
et un peu plus de plages de liberté est
arrivé peut-être plus plus en forme mais
c'est bien qu'ils fin c'est une belle
expérience assez bien pour lui en fait
on est vrai
après ou mac je suis assez content pour
lui parce que je crois qu'il a vraiment
respecté le laisser travailler il a créé
comme un malade depuis deux ans maj
armes en trois ans il a énormément
progressé avants locaux vides il élargit
la perte or à fond il élargit le
répertoire il a changé un peu s'il il
avait perdu du poids
mais on est on est d'accord qu'il avait
il était même un poil en dessous de mvl
avant le
le coc vide ils ont exactement le même
style et il est ressorti du coc vide dix
fois plus fort oui et il a progressé
deux fois les candidats c'est hyper un
peu et d'affiner d'affilée ouais non non
a déjà deux fois c'est énorme c'est avec
une ronde avant ces deux phases écrasé à
chaque fois là cette année encore plus
en fait il a dû procès comme un fou
furieux ans pendant le pendant de la vie
d avant le match de carlson mais on a
toujours dit que c'était un super
talentueux bon rapidement général il
craqué dans les moments importants et
qu'ils foutaient rien que c'est un
fainéant tyrien qui jeux des jeux vidéo
toute la nuit et tout d'un coup il a
quand il a décidé de bosser comme un
malade la différence qu'il a fait il
s'est vraiment mis numéro deux mondial
en fait la personnalité de la vefa les
trois la virtuelle oui mais
mais dans la réalité sur deux depuis la
préco vite c'est lui le numéro deux
mondial clairement tu gagnes deux fois
les candidats tu les écrase au bout d'un
moment mais je m'en fous du vélo en fait
et le boulot qui est indigeste qu'il a
fait mais ça paye il a des idées avec
les blancs sur vos cases sur ces 4 le
même jeu des quatre aides afin de tirer
dit qu'il a bien gagné et mais il a
gagné une tranquillité aussi quand tu le
vois jouer c'est pour ça que pour le
deuxième match qui peut être beaucoup
plus dangereux parce qu'il aura moins à
travailler entre guillemets et pourra
peut-être arriver un peu plus frais or -
le secret qui m'inquiète c'est que dans
chaque interview il dit qu'il est
fatigué
il a dit encore j'ai pas joué deux
parties longues j'ai pas joué deux
parties de 6h machin s'est bien passé
j'ai pu faire des parties courtes
étaient très heureux de ça oui il a fait
des nuls sans jouer c'est le soleil pas
juste il a géré à la perfection il se
croit il se dit fatigué alors faites
quand même attention parce que ici quand
j'ai dit ça y est c'était bien de gérer
ces tournois est de faire des nuls
rapide on m'a quand même dit que
j'aimais pas les échecs l'attention
ouais moi j'ai dit dans un des résumés
que quand tu commences à faire
rapidement des nuls qui peuvent prendre
carmat dans la gueule le lendemain mais
en soi celle cynique et c'est très
efficace et juste un très bon choix
faire un nul sans jouer quand tu peux le
faire c'est juste très bien enfin avec
les noirs fondamentalement mais c'est
juste très peu de cas où c'est un
mauvais choix en fait neuf baisses 99
fois sur 100 c'est le bon choix bam a
mis ko est avec moi ce soir est parti
après actuellement alors pas propre
mais je pense c'est important mais c'est
que tu as beaucoup de gens qui le
comprennent pas en fait oui mais n'aime
pas les échecs bas c'est prague fin
c'est pas une question d' aimer ou ne
pas aimer en fait c'est du pragmatisme
normal en fait sans plus est de la
composition c'est un tournoi donc je
vous presse d'avant tournoi
oui mais c'est comme au tennis si tu
pouvais gagner en trois sets 6 0 6 0 6 0
c'est mieux que tout un long cinq sets
non mais tu aimes pas jouer des matchs
de cinq heures très bien
mais oui c'est plutôt bien et ce avec
n'est pas il a bien géré mais ça peut
être aussi son talon d'achille contre
magnus du coup afin qu il aime faire
durer et lui tient cours
et comme il le sait en plus il va faire
tout pour que ça dure donc ce sera lui
sa stratégie
bien vu ce truc skiset jeu des positions
et gardés de la vie dedans même si
objectivement ryan n'est pas le problème
ça et il peut te faire durer
bah faut qui cessa son entraînement
après ce que tu penses qu'il doit
reperdu point où il doit garder le bide
et la septième ce qu'il a repris 10 kg
ouais il a reçu par bien joué celle ci
est ce qu'il doit pas garder ça
vachement mieux gardés mais qui doit
faire du sport enfin il doit faire bien
des séances de sport
c'est juste pour avoir de l'endurance
sur les pratiques il a longtemps ce que
magnus il veut lui accorder très peu
d'une rapide c'est ça
moi je suis dans la forme de ma vie j'ai
encore pour ridicule que ce matin orange
turcomans du coup un dépôt de découvrir
d'aller courir
mais la chose si je le sens un peu lourd
sur ses appuis
bon d'un autre côté il gagne comme ça
moi je coure 10 km par ahm un coût très
bas c'est lui je le fais en forme
c'est mieux le vélo nous dit
pour m
appartenait pas
retour sur son vélo d'appartement
vraiment bien ce truc là tu sais pas
j'aime bien je pense à l'appareil
français a remarqué combien de temps 10
km j'ai fait aujourd'hui j'ai fait 2 20
5 km 5 minutes donc c'est un camp dit je
pense qu'avec femme si on avait ça tous
les deux ont su rla des courses tout le
temps comment serait très chaud
en fait je crois qu'il peut te mettre
dans la roue va calculs pour que tu as
que tu mets des frottements s'économiser
un peu et du coup tu veux sortir d'un
groupe qui doit frapper d'aller à fond
mais nous je pense qu'on veut on peut
d'ailleurs je ne serai pas un coup de
[ __ ]
j'ai moins bien essayé
mais si on veut monter l'alpe d'huez
avec fab on en a parlé oui je suis pour
un drame en on peut pas quoi te tais toi
tu peux
je m'entraîne ouais ben oui je pense que
mon père je pense que mon père il avait
fait la halle peu deux dames on perd
aussi mais il m'a dit j'étais une très
bonne forme et c'était déjà très dur
pour moi vous n'avez aucune chance je
n'arriverai jamais
faut s'entraider et on perd il était il
faisait beaucoup de vélo ouais
moi jamais arrivé en fait c'est sûr mais
oui quand j'étais gamin je faisais 60
bornes le week-end avec lui tu as oui et
non mais ok j'en ai pas fait trente ans
la musique j'étais petit je vais bien je
m'aide avons même pris un peu de poids
depuis
sa côte et surtout à la belle cote et du
rhin déjà pillé les durs
mais jamais pris un thé vélo j'avais
china's got haïti exactement comme mon
père au premier la ctu pose le pied à
terre mais en fait pourquoi c'est si dur
enfin avec un
peu moins
14% moyens ces 9 ou 11 ans et plus en
fait ça démarre très dur au début et à
la fin qu'il l'aimait tapota beaucoup de
kilomètres à 9 10 % est arrivé à la fin
mais c'est laisser murte à ce qu'avait
fait le truc incroyable
le marathon du jour du lendemain il dit
je vais courir un marathon mais il le
fait pas ça j'en suis incapable
si je m'arrache peut faire 20 mai
marathon géantistes et crise ont brûlé
suite on traite un homme et nous ont
parlé pendant six mois quand même oui on
va pas on n'y va pas de main en fin
d'année mais sans entraînement c'est sûr
qu'on monte pas on fait honnêtement je
pensais durant fins si le loin des
digues soit possible alors le coup ça
valait ce à quoi
les tarnos de gars qui nancie vous
entraîner très bien c'est possible je
sais pas en fait certains nous prennent
vraiment pour des cons on est peut-être
après je sais pas
d'autres croient en nous j'ai du mal à
dire non mais je ne sais pas
vraiment s'entraîner ciment exerce au
pire on fait les chinois et puis
sûrement ne pourront pas voir y'a pas de
déshonneur on a essayé on a en a fait
une petite soirée vendredi à bordeaux il
ya un pari en cours avec sébastien way
doit perdre
10 kilos ouais il est à combien est
lourd de sens là non
ils me renvoyaient ils montent à 102
récemment là ils me renvoyaient l'état
sans il doit faire 90 avant une certaine
date mais je suis plus là donc je vais
pas là bien
c'est pas simple ce marché
danois de l'affluence et le frère des
petites soirées ah c'est ça il m'a dit
je veux pas m'arrêter de vivre
rader petite soirée tu vas manger des
bonbons burger avec des suppléments un
peu partout j'apprends des frites quand
même ça va bien avec un peu de maillots
quoi c'est ce qu'aime samedi ce lieu va
former 12 kg alors leur faut du temps
enfin en fait tu peux les perdent vite
mais ses patrons pour la santé a presque
eu les lys à perdre 2 kg par mois machin
bombe a tué je t'annonce que le braquet
qu'on aura sa lettre à tous petits
gestes ou à gauche enfin moi je suis
celui qui fait le moins de sport mais
gfic d'un cycliste rêverait donc c'est
vrai qu'il ya de l'entraînement
potentiellement
en fait j'aurais pu faire du vélo lieu
des échecs j'aurais été très heureux
j'aurais courru peut-être dans une
équipe et j'aurais fait des stratégies
par les ag2r et hérésie par tarbes on
voit des barrages tout revient sur
le peloton sur toi regarde
mais moi c'est sûr j'ai pas le gabarit
adéquat ans et moi qu'ils drainent plus
m'entraîner il dit à partir de 40 ans
voir un médecin pour le coeur avant de
commencer à monter l'alpe d'huez alors
moi j'ai de la chance parce que j'ai
fait de l'arythmie cardiaque il ya pas
très longtemps mais stellio surmenage en
fait j'ai de la chance dans le sens où
je sais que mon coeur en très bonne
santé notre staff à l'état ouais j'ai
fait des tests et possiblement saleh
n'est pas si longtemps il n'en faut
mener 30 28 mai quant à vichy c'est
tellement c'est ouf ça doit être ça on
peut semer ou alors on fait ça toi toi
tu en as peut-être plus de mal et toi tu
es en voiture et tu me fous la
cua et moi je roule quoi
autre genre de directeur à mais si tu
fais le truc gsm et c'est pourquoi je
suis avec l'oreillette et tout est à
coiffe un fou mais il faut avoir du bon
matos manger j'ai plus de bombay la tête
on peut louer ça
je pense qu'on achète des vélos très
léger je pense quand même 100 g fin
c'est beaucoup mais s'est passé plein de
fric vraiment en gagnant on a économisé
encore 5 g fab et tj récupérer le vélo
que j'avais quand j'étais gamin je
faisais quand j'étais ado j'avais un
petit vélo de course était avec le
dérailleur à l'ancien temps je songe à
la menthe
mais moi j'avais ça aussi sur le cadre
du pouce à quoi attirer
ces plus à offrir à tuffé audois avec de
l'eau pure ça passe encore que d'ici là
cette offre
non non le froid naturel mais après en
courant je suis sûr qu'on y arrive plus
facilement qu'en vélo rue c'est terrible
la cour en enjeu bien marché
il a monté en trente neuf
je roule deux fois trois heures par
semaine je suis monté avec
1,3928 donc 30-28 ça passe ok ça en gros
thon dont plateau devant il est il est
ridiculement petit amas d'ailleurs on
peut vraiment se dire allez dans un an
des seuils parce que là dans six mois de
façon c'est noël donc
mais par contre si on essaye on réussit
enfin en fait c'est ce que mur face m'a
toujours dit malheureusement g33
influencé par mon coach ayant fait tu ne
dois jamais essayé non mais on fait tout
pour mais oui mais ça c'est sûr mais
j'ai en fait faut vraiment tout faire
pour inverser en fait essayer n'est pas
une option a oui mais c'est pas on va
faire un endroit km toujours non mais si
on fait un retour alpe d'huez c'est
c'est pas pour faire de la cie c'est
l'hiver faut la salle de sport et
tourner les jambes
moi je perde du poids que ça
je n'essaye pas je réussis c'est pas une
vraie faille audace et une greffe à
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'est le rêve de
mur tu as honore pas moi je suis
toujours
devant le maso sur un vélo
mais aussi l'appel gabarit n'a pas le
gabarit même un nom plus on va pas se
mentir
j'ai pas trop trop
ok on fait un peu l'eau tomberait marche
et je vais faire semblant de bosser les
gars de laisser ce soir ou jeudi
ouais quand tu l'exo il ya eu un peu des
dons finalement hier nous on essaie de
jeter les gens toute la journée ça s'est
fini comment cette histoire
on a fait le maximum en fait pour
n'envoyer oui c'est avec les
inscriptions du tournoi qui comptait et
du coup j'ai parlé l'aprem avec mon ami
géorgienne qui connaît très bien belle à
niveau mais ils veulent tenter le tout
pour le tout ça marche ou pas il enfin
je les comprends pas fait ils ont raison
enfin on ferait tracé humain oui bien
sûr
je pensais que ça allait mieux mais ça
allait mieux
même vu le petit et après il ya une
rechute est à même pas le temps de
souffler quoi je crois que j'espère ne
pas dire de bêtises khamassi c'est sûr
compliqué mais pour avoir eu un enfant
d'une amie qui était dans le même cas je
crois que pour les enfants le cancer
c'est vraiment très très vite je crois
que c'est vraiment terrible ouais ça se
propage et se rend pas vraiment fair et
conservons
bon sur cette note ou des listes
allez bon
une resucée veille tout bon signe les
web à l'enfant né de mes amis il était
mort après trois quatre ans il avait
soigné deux fois je crois il a refait un
troisième concert le pot
terrible vraiment terrible
un très triste enfin bon c'est comme ça
m'a pris le petit harry caine vécu trois
quatre ans de plus ce tu diffères un
toit s'est pas perdue je sais pas
comment dire il est quand même profiter
il ya eu des périodes de distribution et
une période où il avait enfin entre
guillemets plus de cancers pendante est
un an un an et demi du coup
j'ai pas ils ont fait profiter de la vie
le maximum qu'il était possible mais
c'était vraiment très triste
c'est comme ça c'est la vie
complexe
plombé l'ambiance fab mouais mais ouais
c'était suffit à chaque fois quand tu y
penses tu dis bon du coup l'importance
de la partie double dépôt minatchy par
rapport à ça
non mais tu as déjà se pose des
questions en plus quand tu commences à
apparaître comme ça tu te dis
sortait profiter qu'enfin sortez dehors
en fait
profiter de la vie et de la nature
pendant qu'on peut encore le faire
j'ai quand même regardé combien
gagnent à l'anglais à la cagnotte alors
à temps c'était comment c'était au fond
demi je pense que je vais trouver
après il ya plusieurs sortes de cagnotte
ouais mais alors est ce qu'elles ont et
additionnel n'a pas beaucoup monter la
cagnotte malheureusement sinon après tu
le payes pas ouais ils pêchent pas qu'on
peut voir
il y avait des inscriptions au tournoi
donc je sais pas combien de joueurs
malheureusement on sera très très loin
des 9 1 327 dur
complexe
ma réussite soit pour le truc que
j'avais fait d'aller récolter cinquante
mille euros quand même mais à
[Musique]
juste me pose quand j'ai un coup de fil
à repasser vas-y vas-y fais une pause
vas-y vas-y vas-y pour prendre le temps
un
ouais ouais c'est le jour on va faire on
va refaire déposa ça joue vraiment pour
plus rien les amis du vent plus ce sujet
un peu complexe
vous partez du principe que kara scène
jouera son match c'est parti pour et
puis comme enfin déjà c'est parti pour
premièrement puis comme on le disait
s'ils jouent pas de façon si on part du
principe qu'ils jouent
donc oui la deuxième place jouera pour
rien
malheureusement
championne du monde apparemment en fait
ça va être en avril
on pensait que ce serait
en mars mois j'avais lu mars de base
mais apparemment ça va être avril
je sais pas où d'ailleurs je crois pas
que ce soit annoncé
réussi
surexcité en fin d'année ouais c'est un
peu bizarre parce qu'en fait avant c'est
en novembre du coup ils rechange de da
dont c'est pas
après faut laisser le temps un peu entre
la fin des candidats et le match pour
pour la prépa justement
elle atteint 20 7 avril
faut au moins six mois contre eux donc
là où il sera peut être janvier 2023
mais on peut importer on n'est plus à
une incohérence près
on sait où s'organisent et ben je crois
pas moi j'espérais chine mais ça valait
le cas avec ding
peut-être norvège au final un papa
magnus à domicile je crois qu'il aime
pas oui mais bon enfin oui non je n'aime
pas la cadence et même pas faim
s'il n'a pas encore d'organisateurs pas
encore de date wallon mais c'est vrai
que ça peut être étonnant 20-20 parce
que la date de la coupe du monde 2022 8
de foot on doit déjà connaître j'imagine
prend fin moi je sais pas mais oui et
globalement des gros événements comme ça
c'est pas annoncer dernière minute les
dates
fait l'organisateur pour expliquer aux
dates mais à mon plan portent
qu'ils me montrent 2028 et ce qu'on a
déjà les dates
ouais ce sera du lundi 8 juin alors
commis en dessous le 26 avril 2026
2000-2001 de suite si bête ouais c'est
du 8 juin 2000 26 au 3 juillet 2026 et
coupe du monde 2030 du coup est ce qu'on
a dans sa housse à domino et je pense
qu'on veut savoir mais on doit savoir
non neutre entre aix et déjà bruit
2000 2003 que 2026 ou 2030 je crois pas
qu'on est déjà distribuée sans vous dis
ok on est bien on sait quatre ans avant
sera ce soir là couillon de 2026 non
c'est 2026 ou
2030 on sait pas apparemment ça ne
manque pas été attribué au caire
en fin de cette coupe du monde aux usa
mais pourquoi pas à 2,94 mais je veux
dire je peux faire de belles vacances
le binôme espagne-portugal fut plus que
jamais favori pour accueillir le mondial
2030 ça peut être sympa à ça et il est
de gauche pouilles nov
c'est la mode maintenant d'ailleurs dans
deux pays en même temps que celui d'un
enfant longtemps c'était juste ouais
mais fade c'est assez compliqué à mon
avis
ça se décide en 2024 donc l'organisation
et les dates donc si l'on six ans à l'as
vence
et je vois déjà les dates de roland
garros 2023 bah oui
c'est sûr
ouais et 2024
devant une bonne idée quoi
non ils annoncent une saison sur l'autre
tennis la saison c'est une saison sur
l'autre
et en 2024 utilise à une longueur aura
un toit
et mais des toits par tous et
simone mathieu il ya déjà un toit
et jeux olympiques 2000
enfin je sais pas s'il a déjà un taux de
mathieu darche est pas une connerie
c'est le truc dans la sarthe genou il
voit déjà les dates
ouais géo 2028 on a les dates du trou 21
juillet au 6 août c'est ou
los angeles c'est bien ça aussi et 2032
on a déjà les dates du 23 juillet au 8
août donné 32 hockey
brisbane
allez donc en fait les way et nous on
sait pas si à ceux des dates du truc qui
a dans huit mois les mecs savent ce qui
va se passer dans dix ans quand emma la
taille des plots
annoncé dingue en fait c'est quand ils
pensent
et 2036 ça peut-être pas ça ne t'aime
pas tribune oui mais dire c'est qu'ils
en course villes candidates si fin ils
font déjà l'attribution
il ya de nouveaux los angeles qui se
présentent à elles vont pas faire tout
le temps
alors il a alexandrie fin los angeles
alexandrie budapest bueno ars cologne
francfort et nuremberg
dublin et helsinki lausanne rio de
janeiro et rome
annoncent assez pour 2000 non désolé
c'est pour 2026
désolé désolé
j'ai dit une bêtise
donc apparemment il ya l'inde qui est
peut-être favorite mais est ce que tu
voulais donc fait trop chaud qui fait
peut-être trop chaud pour faire les jeux
olympiques d'été là je pense
j'en suis donc une chance manne pour
gagner
donc c'est bien face
mais à istanbul aussi 2036 candidate
le caire
pas la même ampleur d'événements non
plus mais ne passera les dates pour dans
huit mois c'est chaud non mais bien sûr
c'est pas tout à fait comparable mais
bon géré par la classe et dans huit mois
oui quand-même fin je lui en demande pas
savoir maintenant d'avancement
d'un 6 sur l'autre quoi
doit on sait même pas s il ya déjà des
villes candidates pour organiser les
ondes et c'est quelqu'un là on est comme
aucun écho a pas un peter
et vraiment beaucoup de gens qui se
déplacent pour le championnat du monde
d'échecs à part tout l'écosystème n'y a
absolument personne d'ailleurs si tu
vois les photos de magnus guiry et tous
les gens les joueurs d'échecs de premier
plan qui jouait dans le parc il y avait
quasiment personne d'extérieur à
l'écosystème des échecs la plupart
c'était des journalistes ou des streamer
mais il y avait peut-être je sais pas où
une quinzaine de badauds quoi
une vingtaine mais non
donc non non championnat du monde il ya
très peu de personnes peut-être on zappe
l'opposition
jeune homme tout le monde dépose un peu
plus un échec patent a fléchi série de
fausses armes et c'est là tu te dis il
vaut mieux le foot ça me prendrait un
temps qu'on attendait 8 puis mais
sympa quoi
comme tu veux après aussi moyen de faire
la pause parce qu'il va être 16 heures
comme tu veux
voire peut être coup
car à 9 sur 11 heures ça va jouer
sa place les pièces et qu'est-ce qu'on a
d'autres rapportent le plus ou moins le
même genre de trucs bio oui mais tombe
bien j'attends le pitch your way c'est
digne il va bien en b3 et il ya plus
d'hommes ça tu mets ton est cette per
qu'on apprenne
à jouer on te prend quoi ça fait de leur
groupe qui font plus tâche et
restaurants c'est un jeune trader
français si quinn tout cool taxi
chez city index des one shot the queen
rooks ex
big three kings of seventeen de douceur
9xx
high
tech
bio au
chapitre ailleurs
atteint 10,6
finning de bornes
moi je peux vous qu'il préfère à 2 à b 3
mais il préfère peut-être qu'il a vu à 5
un moment vraiment touché
le petit coucou est sorti
et alan marrant et hikaru quand même
ti coca à côté du fanta au le starbucks
qui part après match il a doublé double
caféine qu'au café tu as déjà vu
quelqu'un voir un peu de coca puis à
prévoir un peu de
blessés c'est pas possible en fait
personne ne fait ça et voir un petit
arbre n 3 une canette de fanta
j'adore enfin je peux pas m'empêcher
d'adorer n'a qu'à cause de ça en fait
à literally dons de pierres non il ya
exceptionnel heureusement qu'il est là
quand même pour des journées comme ça
franchement j'adore ça
il est vraiment extraordinaire note n'a
qu'à
c'est le boss on
critique si one a dit
c'est une petite chapelle tout hacking
de pores servant
technique des one design
tout à fond le
black is ok
c'est un vrai génie du coup si on fait
appel
tout
one ok mais tu y as matin donc ça va en
un coup de répit
ne serait pas sex
king en douceur
night attaque cependant à y fut
hélas arrivé
regarde ce plafond est
laissé aux grecs tactique
ni power
tools shift 4g marais trois ans caméra 3
1 43e
dépôt passe
un peu dans la
ville at t
et ses bars et ses
dignes qui revient
geraci records mais
dommage que ce soit le jour du transfert
tour de france vous a fait un bond à 6
de bowling
technique
il se passe quoi du côté de wimbledon on
l'a vu dimanche et lundi alors lundi
deux mineurs admire ouangani gagarine va
fouiller les deux sets zéro les deux
mineurs ouais là ces deux sets partout 4
partout dans le troisième chouf quiriau
ce qui sut un peu compte nakashima ah
bon un set partout mais nakashima il est
bon en fait un faux pas sous-estimer
j'ai vu jouer plusieurs fois c'est un
bon joueur l'américain américain ouais
mais beau joueur en fait
ce qui sera atcha
tubulaire contre fritz frites si je vous
parle alain il souffrira contre alpha 0
stockfisch mais
effrayé dans
ce premier jeu immanent davo il a marqué
son service il a sauvé quatre balles de
break et là il a une balle de break on
va voir la préhistoire ta van van den
zone chute mais en fait si l'effort
ce
25e mondial c'est paris qui quoi
explique olé sort de nulle part et que
depuis il clique vie facile peut battre
nadal est un qui a la plus grande
histoire une armada de saint paul aux
galates chef non
oui mais certains disent qu'ils étaient
peut-être dopé à ma charge il ya des
rumeurs voient se feront sentir de nulle
part quoi c'est qui lui aussi est là de
la même ville que llena absa
oui on est lundi à my bad
après je pense contre nadal c'est dur
mais le tableau en quart ça va donner
quoi djokovic sinner bon ça gagne ça
dégage
goffin nourrit 3 n'aurait envoyé un bon
document final au caire après ça sur ma
faim deux mineurs peut-être nakache et
avec que ces faibles
et puis je suis en finale au jour
personne n'est par contre fritz nadal
ouais ça pour le coup
[Musique]
il ya corner thannois est-ce que tan va
tenir donc vous les rybacki nike s'est
qualifié contre martigues il y aura
corner tomljanovic mais tomanovic
attention peut être dangereux sur gazon
a juré contre yb a acquis des encarts et
thann contrat ni simova manie simova
hyper dangereuse
allez-vous tenir soutenir thann
oui moi je suis rang pour thann dans son
histoire harmonie en plus son prénom
j'aime bien
faut qu'elles tiennent
jeudi qui pile qui équipe les maquis
fils
charles ekoko reprise appelle les cocos
en fait mais à
arsenault deux filles j'ai pas noix de
coco c'est l'été
il fait bon dans son essai c'est fou
on n'a pas l'arrêt fait
noix de coco c'est l'été mais non j'ai
pas le j'ai passé une pub
bouge c'est une invention quoi
eh les gars dji'ala limiterait
tout autre bémol bon
parce que se sentirait pas une pause
vers 10,2 je savais changer at ban
comme un mario kart ya peut-être la
jetée pour faire face et niveau et c'est
de le rattraper elle serait beau et ce
pour un petit turbo
insectes pendant
pendant que mathieu faisait le récap
j'ai gagné en trois victoires une
défaite
dans mario foot
il eu des matches très serrés 1 c'était
4,3 machin tu as fait l'art avec le goal
et a tenu
à saluer une tornade là une frappe
tornade je sais pas frappe il tient le
ballon tu vas te fait que des cliniques
comparant les cages avec toi tu recules
eh bien c'était 10 secondes à jouer
et fin du match que
olivier thomas sq
mais en plus c'était dur parce que y en
fait il vaut à des fins il joue à deux
mois je suis seule et ils m'ont fait il
y en a un qui a défoncé d'altavia coudes
épaules du coup il est resté tout seul
un jeu peut plus intervenir en fait
les joueurs du fus mario strikers ya
moyen de jouer sérieux avec mais j'ai vu
que l'estrie murray mais pas du tout
mais je comprends pas moi je trouve ça
marrant mais après comme j'ai zéro
expérience dans les jeux vidéo peut-être
qu'il est complètement nul et que moi
j'aime bien c'est possible ce que je
joue absolument rien
vivement les matches et que ça à dire
enfin après c'est marrant comme je le
fais pas
après ce serait bien qu'ils aient des
tournois des genres de switch rivals des
trucs comme ça ça pourrait être marrant
mais moi je m'amuse bien mais je sais
pas pourquoi tout le monde à tous les
streamer lyon shih tzu plus
mais je sais pas moi je trouve marrant
bon je pars à moitié je regarde juste
comme ça mais je dis pas
bref vous êtes aussi ce qu'ils font pas
dopé peut-être peut-être qu'ils payent
pas pour que tu joues aussi je sais pas
ça peut être aussi n'ont aucune idée
nettement shopping
mais je me dis ok peut-être que nintendo
il propose aucune aucune seconde soit
rien il est pasri mahb longue durée je
sais pas j'ai pas d'avis
il ne fait jamais dopé ok 2 hearts est
gavé je me rends pas compte en fait
kenzy mais je pense ça manque de
tournois ou deux trucs ouais c'est ça je
sais pas je me rends pas compte
comme je dis j'ai aucune expérience je
sais pas pourquoi moi je le trouve
marrant mais après c'est vrai tu cliques
3,88 chaussures joue le lendemain c'est
pas non plus la fin j'ai pas deux heures
d'affilée en fait aujourd'hui jouer 20
minutes 1 et je n'avais pas joué quatre
fois vingt minutes en un mois
chose
mais ça prend beaucoup de temps
ouais après je pense que ce qui se passe
c'est que wayne on est des gens qui
avons maximum une demi heure par jour
pour un jeu vidéo et c'est vrai que
quand tu si tu joues 7 8 heures par jour
aux jeux vidéo et le jeu doit être très
limité on est donc oui je peux
comprendre en fait
mais après d'un autre côté ils font à
francfort ne gagne pas c'est un peu
limité aux cieux
la pause
on sait la pause let's go à l'est
visuellement il se passe pas grand chose
frappe dans cette partie
rien de rien de grave en attendait pas
grand chose de cette journée
là on n'est pas déçu il de soins du la
voilà on n'est pas déçu
alors que roanne à
lui il joue
duda
ça joue aussi
rapport tu vois pas la richarde
rajout vraiment pour rien en fait la
partie qu'à roanne a rejeté à trois
parties qui jouent vraiment pour rien en
fait ya qu une partie qui a de l'enjeu
ça doit aussi leur part nul assez vite
mais qui devrait finir par annuler a
sévi donc le tournoi sera vraiment
complètement clos à ce moment là j'ai
envie de dire au revoir la course à kurt
bock way course à la cuillère de bois
way the wooden spoon comme disent les
anglais
mais après comme on le lisait un vu les
dernières avancées au niveau de 47 de la
fidh et tout ça sans qui va jouer aussi
quand il arrive quand on lui a demandé
est ce que tu vas jeu contre l'epo il a
dit reid nos un truc comme ça en
rigolant ce qui semblait plutôt semblé
dire ah oui j'ai pas pris maintien de
jeu ouais je comprends pas pourquoi il
maintient le mystère autour de ça
j'en sais rien en fait va je ne capte
pas le délire moi j'ai jamais cru qui
jouait pas
mais bon hélas oui ça sent il en est
plutôt dire un je ne sais pas
ironique je ne sais pas
utiliser un peu le truc normal
précise rien en fait
pat on s'en fout quoi de sa décision va
de cirque
zhu zhu pets avait fait sa life a pas
plus mon balai qui joue qui joue pas
[Musique]
moi c'est pas une attendre c'est même
agaçant en fait ce que je trouve où
c'est irrespectueux de
leur habitat ce qu'il a répondu je vais
devoir twitter le matin est ce qu'ils
avaient annoncé par mer demain peut-être
bon je suis
enfin il est pas en position de pouvoir
le faire mais bon
mais bon à mon avis là pour moi il a
plus ou moins répondit oui en faisant ça
mais bon
je suis d'autant futur qui va jouer si
carbo termine deuxième pour bien sûr que
par contre ça sera un levier pour la
fidh la troisième ne joue pas car aux
champions du monde musiques à ouïr c'est
très très bien pour la fidh c'est encore
mieux pour annualisé l'icc haroon et pau
que ouais ouais ouais t'as le russe sont
l'américain
ta hikaru streamer toute la commune qui
va suivre donc en gros engouement machin
en fait c'est pas comme si tu
présenterait en face à un très beau
match à faire car tu veux pas jouer je
vous passe tu veux jouer bas tu fais
souvent nos conditions parfaites fin
jeudi mal à comprendre en quoi tu es en
position de force pour négocier quoi que
ce soit
hikaru
icare on est pauvre et plus de buzz que
magnus n'est pas aux sacs là on a donc
là en fait oui c'est vrai qu'ils
perdraient complètement son levier
a pas de levier rien quoi
faire pour la fidh dont je pense
je pense pas c'est sûr que pour eux le
mieux c'est et hikaru vainqueur
mais à ménéz paul ricard ouais je suis
d'accord avec ton affable ça ferait un
tel un tel buzz
pas de ces écarts ou deuxième c'est même
mieux pour les échecs magnus refuse de
jouer en réalité mais il accepte donc on
sera un monde imaginaire
ouais enfin monde imaginaire
après on sait plus trop quoi raconter
aussi donc on essaie d'inventer des
mondes quoi
ça sympa de faire le match de
championnat du monde où tu avais joué
par équipes là dans le stade du werder 1
par exemple
tu aimais sur la pelouse moi je veux
dans les loges
on dit juste magnus kikwit c'est un méga
buzz j'ai enfin par exemple magnus qui
était à madrid pour faire des beats en
direct ça va pas amener foule un nom
mais s'ils quittent qui toi ça fera par
les genres comme kasparov avait arrêté
c'était un s'attendait pas
mais l'actualité du journal de 20h et
grands formats de
dans le milieu des échecs ça fera jaser
mais enfin pas puisque ça non plus quoi
en soi juste pas défendre la couronne
wen ont arrêté les échecs ce serait
dingue
le ti coca
mais j'adore en fait mais le chiffre
mais c'est dégueulasse de voir du
starbucks du blocage juste après non ça
va tellement pas ensemble sata s'édifie
l'estomac mais bon il faut les
résistants
ils étaient tranquilles il fait le pain
un peu dans son fauteuil
non mais magnus pour moi il ya plus de
suspense il va jouer puis je crois qu'il
ya jamais eu de suspense en faites ce
que
je dis
arrivé je crois que même en fait le truc
chaise comme est plus en forme de pêche
français
voient pas
ce cas le droit de sortir une bière
pendant sa game et je pense que si tu
caches le
le contenant que tu mettais les petits
sacs en
vous tue mais une autre une autre
bouteille je pense que tu as le droit
on bosse
une bière ça va
après si tu
[Musique]
mets s c'est vraiment pas dopants à
devoir là dessus
[Musique]
tu mets une 8 6-7 8-6 ouais ouais non
c'est pas terrible odeur
c'est pas un super dopants quoi j'ai
envie de dire
ouais je pense pas que ce soit face
mieux jouer
nos petits chats on a plus
pareils on se fait plaisir c'est bon
c'est orange un genre de machin c'est
pas mal
mais je pense pas que ça va trop non
plus de doper quoi je crois c'est déjà
plus intéressant oui bah c'est déjà
mieux que de boire
mais après par contre être en état
d'ébriété je pense que c'est interdit
ouais puis d'autant plus tu déranges les
autres ou ton adversaire déjà ça t'a pas
loin de déranger l'adversaire
mais bon c'est pas adam son machin
starbucks un vrai
oui dans son cocker
je pense que remplir une canette de coca
et qu'autre chose ce n'est pas forcément
simple
quinze ans après je crois que les jeux
les bulles ou les ouvrir ses canettes
c'est plusieurs à trop de choses auront
président de la fide viens de le dire
sur le casse alors c'est quand je ne m
juste le clip rate on va écouter un
remarque
si
je te dis
c'est pas le président de la fila
convenant à un
baiia pas de deadline
10 le 20 juillet mais bon c'est pas
obligatoire n'ont plus faim c'est fou en
fait jean deutsch qui sert à rien nos
formes nice deadline pas entièrement
officiel mais 20 juillet
s'est pas formalisé pas de notre
sa place je réponds pas le 20 juin mais
c'est incroyable de se faire autant
marcher dessus qua
non moi je dis tu réponds tu vas jusqu'à
ce soir minuit j'ai pas de réponse aux
articles ou pas ça n'a qu'un bas vous
serez très vite vu quand
et comment tu veux que ça marche bien en
fait c'est pas possible
bercy j'ai pas demandé ça avant en fait
danser n'importe quoi
sarr que la tâche fini le truc est donc
officiellement en fait on sait pas qui
sait quel sera le match de lyon c'est
hallucinant fait
d'en bloquer ces car ça ne l'est pas
mais jusque là chez face à faire mon
caprice de
ne pas dire une donc officiellement mais
peut-être que carl scène il va chercher
des sponsors pour faire un match à côté
et faire comme karpov une scission avait
cassé l'appareil si je suis content de
la fidh je dis si tu vas jouer le truc à
côte et à poura de faire un seul tour
rapide des suspendus dix ans m'a bien
sûr été très vite dans lequel elle donc
le studio va jouer le truc à côté mais
tu seras suspendu deviendra plus jamais
jouer un tour le fils
et son adversaire pareil ah bah oui oui
bon une avance qui jouerait un circuit
un truc
ce serait très dur
et je verrai si t'es pas un peu comme ça
à montrer les dents évidemment ils ont
fait un truc comme ils veulent et ils
s'en [ __ ]
oui on n'a pas fait une vraie ça pousse
ça pourrait peut-être le veut le 20
juillet way la bataille woods s'est joué
à toi une dizaine en mai ces
familles rigole ce barème et fabi la
raison enfin c'est comme on en discutait
c'est comme vous ils me le donne là
tu as voulu inventer des règles n'est
plus un tournoi atp point barre en fait
ça va même plus loin et wimbledon c'est
encore plus gros car la scène en fait
comparativement mais ils s'en foutent en
fait non mais si tu n'étais pas une
fédération forte en fait tu te plais
tinée
sa patte l'institution bottes la coi
à tapas de choix ouais
tu dois être fort
ça fait tellement pas pro de laisser les
trucs en suspens balle à un truc comme
ça en plein tournoi et tout c'est vrai
ça fait ultra amateurs en fait
d'un airbus étaient des gens qui
regardent balle à vous tous
bon certains sont habitués quoi aborder
de nouveaux qui comprennent pas ce que
tu regardes et pourquoi tu regardé et
c'est quoi l'enjeu en fait quel est le
premier qualifié pour le contre 45
d'être qui jouera pas alors peut-être le
deuxième et peut-être pas on connaît
même pas le format du match championnat
du monde parce que du coup c'est parfois
très qualifiés
c'est violent qu'en fait quand
l'amateurisme du du truc
verrait combattre s'était pas qualifié
programme pour vous après les candidats
toi tu vas en vacances non ouais je
parle aux états unis un peu en vacances
après le prochain truc spécial bitstream
c'est le stage à lisbonne en fait ouais
alors il y aura des vidéos dans l'été
sur la chaîne etc mais le prochain gros
événement en fait c'est le stage donc à
lisbonne 13 au 20
si vous êtes chauds et à 100 voire
quelques places
et puis après je sais pas il y aura
peut-être des trucs à la rentrée
d'autres après un fond vert
france en septembre quoi
sur cet été ah non à priori rien d'autre
que ça ouais
si
constructive une lettre au président
cannois rck ça fait flipper quand même
bon 26h comment ce qu'il fait mais se
laisse marcher dessus
il faut pas 13 au 20 août quicks 13 au
20 août il ya ba sur le site d'un
formulaire ça t'intéresse tu peux nous
écrirons donnant les enseignements même
si ce n'est pas pour cette année comme
on compte en refaire à l'avenir toute
façon ça pèse d'une prise de contacts
etc
ross un bon stage
magnifique même
colas match qui est l'enjeu voilà pour
plus ou moins finir second des candidats
ce qui normalement sert à rien
installé à toulouse on demandera ben je
pense pas de sitôt
les mains stage j'avais fait à
montpellier là il n'y a pas si longtemps
ne savait pas été un
si grand succès il ya un peu du mont ham
et à part les grosses villes en france
ça draine pas grand monde à voir lyon
parilly way et après après à l'étranger
nous on aime bien parce que ça fait un
peu vacances pas de connaître les gens
sachent australie un peu plus dur
ne peut plus dire
presse avec arsène ice bar à vegas pour
un bon d'avoir de series of poker ouais
je vais vous le vsop va peut-être que
moi aussi coiffe un match est peut-être
le croiser ouais
mais c'est beau en fait si je suis au
top quoi
après je pense qu'il vous celui à 10000
dollars et par satellite tout ça je vais
rien faire
il sponso par unibet
[Musique]
mais si tu as changé la règle du texas
hold'em en plein de sera double s opérer
mais ouais c'est intrigant
ses histoires avec la fidh ces machins
et il
du nom fait plus dorée cap parce que les
partis n'ont plus d'enjeu mais ce soir
on fera une vidéo finale ouais avec le
classement final ça tout ça
oui vu que ça joue pour plus rien
il n'y a plus rien à voir
prend pour émettre le stream de sardes
nomique
jeu sans micro samson quoi
pour rejoindre et kloten
alors il encore en train de jouer sarde
en nomique web facile à papa demi qu
un jour
c'est nomique nono cam quoi
tu as ta bulle de rêve qui regarde lui
aussi en même temps mais on peut se
mettre un peu de sarnaut aussi
à la casse sur
[Musique]
essai cascio c'est ça c'est lui en jaune
là est en train de monter avec saccacio
les petits
ouais
les sbires font des petits dégâts de mer
de s'intéresser ça mais c'était sbires
du coup ça ça ne sert à pas t d autres
ça rend le jeu dynamique
je passe la game se passe bien on arrive
en plein milieu on sait pas trop quoi
on met un message dans son chat
vas-y 1
tant vas-y un fight là il ya un gros
fail tu attends il va mourir je pense
qu'il a presque plus de vie mais je sais
pas qui gagne le teamfight
ils ont l'air pas mal
qui fait mal c'est quoi ces annonces et
un outil luce assez terrible ils se font
il faut dépenser ils sont sept emplois
qui s'échappe il a flash
mlc courir après je pense qu'à se faire
défoncer non ça reste un espoir bien
séparés
bon c'est pas très bon signe pour leurs
équipements bah je sais pas mais ils ont
l'air d'être assez avancés ils ont
sont déjà vraiment dans le camp adverse
je pense qu'ils sont assez bien personne
et tout ça il est en train de défoncer
un truc
samassa
sebo pour être sarno mis knock am
beaucoup plus intéressant les candidats
en fait
sinon c'est yahoo nomique mais william
parce qu'ils ont un chat
la game et des oreilles mais nous on
arrive en plein
-c'est-à-dire joue le sort non
ouais ouais sont perçus est revenu
mais regardez vers un nouveau team fight
on regarde on en est là c'est bien ce
qu'il a fait ce hard il a fait un genre
de file sont les défoncer il a super
raisonnable centreur comme des coûts
voilà là il ya une team fight ils vont
gagner la game
je pense
ouais je pense ils ont gagné la mélasse
hard il a super bien joué
ouais c'est win
je pense il a bien joué après je suis
pas je suis pas bon du tout mais d'après
ce que je comprends il a fait un bond
bons
baisers repasse aux candidats
et les gens sont très heureux dans le
chatt six games s'est rien passé un tour
d'essai un mois pas eu de quoi et les
autres vont jusqu'à
karana chez rogers renfe
duda niveau
ça bougeait quand même le voir depuis à
complexe
moi
[Musique]
bon ok
game de saintes m mais à chaud rien ah
oui of
né peut perdre il peut ne pas venir la
partie faire ce qu'ils veulent et déjà
gagné le tournoi
oui ouais et alors on fait ça changerait
ça fait rien en fait
les deux peuvent faire des deux pour
gagner
plus rien ne changera rien en fait
les dés sont jetés
the dice a
rolling
rowling dice un
aléa jacta est un
dresseur caste
peut-être d'assises a rejeté dans yes
beaucoup plus anglais bien sûr
on va rester sur n'a cassé la seule
partie qui est un microscopique intérêt
mais bon vu la gueule de la position
bon on a bien vu la menace tout reprend
ses ischios sain et qu'il a fait faux
des six pour briguer pas de fourchette
ans le 5
complexe
fabrice bailly s'est déjà plurielle
c'est plus rien de quoi de die en die
die risque un décès ou die
die hard
ok monde ait déjà pluriel je pense que
ces cellules effectivement
passé les dés sont jetés 300 médailles
ok
mais pas de taille 6 peut-être mon perso
préféré sur la bassée cascio obligé
oui c'est complètement obligatoires
ces deux faits par ding
doubler les tours
neuf analystes nous y avoir du monde
dans ce genre de trucs ouais
donc attention quand même des cas ça n'a
l'air de rien c'est rien
ça joue bien en face
je reviens de chez steam sur lol je
crois que jules joué très bien
fois qu il était quasi challenger quand
même
mais clairement moi il faudrait que je
joue support ou dans la jungle ainsi
obligatoire
fanmi de lijn
ces surfaces put envie de lijn qui
se veut décisif je connais pas trop sur
le jeu donc fait à 3 lane et à des
jeunes lgbt à moi je serai support à
essai sur
jules stardash c'est possible mais c'est
très possible
ok jules il clique très vite et qu'il
s'est fait
ramener poney poète et semi pro ado tac
enfin c'est juste que oui ça clique un
peu quoi
après il a complètement arrêté il n'a
pas le temps jules mais oui c'est ça
file très très fort je crois
mais bon ciné pause s'était mis à fond
alors ça qui crée très très violemment
s'il aurait pu être pro player c'est sûr
fin vu qu'il a été super bon à dota et
qui n'a pas trop de temps vu qu'ils
jouent aux échecs c'est sûr que s'il
avait voulu être pro et sa turbine vite
en fait
il a joué semi-pro fin tu as joué
semi-pro camp
[Musique]
quand c'est pas ton jeu made who is it
escrimeurs et que ça devient ton jeu
mail à mon avis tu va être très violent
quoi
et pau il aurait été très violent c'est
sûr elle vaut quoi name sco d'ailleurs
vu qu'on parle d'échec de lol de ce truc
là elle vaut quoi lol meme sco
platine gold
dit pas ouf enfin sa clique un peu quand
même un jour sans fin chaque
boeing
enfin ils sont c'est tous des c'est tous
des silver un silver de et ça parle
est-ce que j'ai concernés pour un
premier tournoi je vous vite et bien
conseils de kevin na pas être appliquée
par firoud jared jouer vite et bien
c'est toujours un bon conseil et le
warrant le conseil phare de mon de mon
coach
très efficace quand tu réussis à le
mettre en place
on pour progresser et jouer les
meilleurs coups bah oui c'est très fort
ça aussi mais moi mieux que j'ai vite et
bien non je vais vite et bien c'est
vraiment puissant
jeune tchèque et le vieux comptes de
l'épaule sans vrai qu'ils aient joué un
peu ado thayer
ce serait normal un attendant est
derrière lui et qu à cliquer un peu du
dota ça fait toujours plaisir
souffle beau jeu dota
j'ai une copine qui joue pas mal à dota
ghana
tu te rappelles forcé mondiale
je pense que iana c'est pas genre de
personne qu'on peut oublier si
facilement
il joue à dota 2 elle joue pas mal
files de femmes femmes femmes qui lâche
0 info
on doit partir certainement pas en vache
morte
tu attends quoi tranquille fab un
bail à rien quand y'a rien à dire
quand y'a rien à dire ne dit rien en
fait
le comté de match de tennis peut-être
au match de tennis aussi de certains
pour curieuse
de sa clique de part et d'autre ayant
dit qu'il se barre il retourne voir saab
après tu peux laisser le sont ici on
nomique nomique nos gammes
on sait également progressé il vaut
mieux jouer un mauvais plan que pas de
point du tout part en fait j'avais un
conseil s'est vu tous les bons plans
[Musique]
lorient n'a pas révélé fin de cette
seconde dans les échecs après moi j'ai
vu un extrait du truc d'hier c'est
vraiment bien paris
a joué le bon plan évite toi aussi
important vite
qu'elle est à des gestes je veux en fait
je vais vegas et je monte vers san
francisco après
ce sera tout ne sera déjà beaucoup
en fait c'est ouais ça fait une trotte
tu passes par les parcs nationaux les
margouillats
ok là je le bon truc n'est
toujours pas claire la position
mais là ça joue bien cette partie en
fait
après ils étaient préparés très loin
il a quelqu'un y clic
c'est quand même un peu peur non la
position
ouais mais après il s'en fout oui parce
qu'il se fait qui fait absolument rien à
[ __ ] toi qui sont souvent devant c'est
plus facile de jouer ça quand tu joues
plus pour rien mais oui je suis d'accord
avec toi mais après c'est pas pareil en
fait ce pas la même tension n'en est pas
du tout car moins
c'est de bâtir petit à petit son petit
truc
c'est beau hein
et c'est de faire comme can't do
dacquois way de clics et puis peut être
un petit truc
vous prend qui va les prend et sûrement
il va jouer pour la colonne c'est
l'emprunt quelque chose c'est toujours
très solide mais bon on sait pas
wedding un peu mieux mais
ça peut devenir intéressant
thor est ce que ce serait pas là la
pause la petite pause de 17 à tout à
l'heure les amis
les amis j'ai un petit peu regardez ce
que ça disait pendant la pause
côté fidh
sassus un peu en fait ça sur un peu
parce que
en fait ils veulent négocier mais pas
trop avec karl scène
tu as l'impression qu'il y avoir une
prise d'otages et que etc la fidh
gentil c'est la police dans l'est dans
les films de prise d'otage quoi ils
veulent un peu négocier avec les
preneurs d'otages mais pas trop non plus
sassus à moitié quoi s'assurer à moitié
c'est ouais se seraient pas bien si mag
ne jouais pas mais on peut pas tout
accepter non plus
je sais pas si vous voyez le délire
t'as vu ça ou sur twitter giraud tweet
du coup le moment intéressant
car le satde négocié mais ouais c'est
très étrange dans le sens où il négocie
en plein milieu du truc quoi serait
vraiment comme si après la demi-finale
de roland ont négocié avec avec les
joueurs pour voir comment on joue la
finale c'est très très bizarre
c'est très très très très très très
étrange
caprice de diva ben non je dirais pas
parce qu'en fait je pense qu'il a raison
sur le fond et il a tort sur la forme
car le scène pour moi et a complètement
raison
d'après ce que je comprends il a
complètement tort sur la forme d'après
moi c'est juste pas le bon timing
mais il a raison sur le fond calmes
ils négocient la durée il négocie les
cadences d'après ce que je comprends et
il veut peut-être aussi un système de 7
ckoi sur l'éducation qui les ont pas
officialisé ses revendications serre qui
laisse les gens dans le flou bon ils
prennent un peu pour des cons en gros
mais
est en gros je pense que c'est plus de
rapides plus de 7
il va la gagner en fait dit mme meilleur
joueur de de la position sur le circuit
je passais veut gagner mais il a alors
enchaîné un petit quelque chose
car ça déjà profiter tous les candidats
pour des raisons de forme à je me
rappelle pas voilà en 2010 ou chez
huawei est refusé en 2011 les pages eux
et ils s'étaient qualifiés
pas où des peuples par ce truc mais mais
il avait montré son désaccord
mais je sais pas c'était le formal pour
l'un ou le leu
l'avantagé du champion 1 6 l avantage du
champion qu'il est
la banlieue mais je crois que c'est ça
qui le gêne parce que moi de bosser les
déclarations de 2010 et qu'ils étaient
contre le privilège du champion mais il
n'a pas joué
il a refusé 2009 et 2011
à jouer les candidats et 2007 c'est sûr
ouais match contre à rognan dont je vous
parlais après je crois pas
particulièrement
faudrait revoir mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il était contre le truc des
champions
d'ouvrir les échanges dont il a pu
changer d'avis entre temps m dagan des
champions c'est cool quand ça l'arrangé
non mais sur le fait qu'il faille
changer de le format est là il a raison
après c'est pas le faire juste après le
match contre des pots en fait un tu
viennes le truc étudie bon bah voilà
c'était un peu de la merde on pourrait
te faire si si et ça pour que ça soit
mieux et la voilà oula tu dis rien taton
ce match et tu fais juste après
en fait le problème du coup c'est le
problème de la sélection comme le dirait
non à une phrase c'est qu'en fait on a
sélectionné du coup les joueurs sur un
format et si c'est pour jouer sur un
autre forme assez bizarre quoi
tout
vient de gazon ontario en finale 1 tient
en fait ce sera la terre battue
le privilège du champion n'existe plus
messieurs auparavant en quatre matches
le champion a esté champions oui je sais
pas de ça dont on parle en fait avec le
champion à ce champion et là pas de
cycle a joué pendant que les autres on
les candidats ont tout à faire avant ils
doivent se préparer pour les candidats
il sort toutes leurs nouveautés toi tu
es tranquille et le mec qu'a pas le
temps de souffler qui doit déjà se
préparer je viens du monde simon après
dakar est un privilège
mais à l'inversé que la fidh en aurait
pas rien à [ __ ] ils s'étaient après le
match championnat du monde banon se
seraient mais vous
bien sûr que non mais
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce qu'ils
comprennent pas le timing voit pas c'est
juste évident il n'y a pas débat de ça
ça ne va pas et points en cette période
un autre à dire
après sa part peut-être aussi de l'échec
de sa plateforme à nuit en fait moi je
moi au début quand il a fait ça quand il
a dit que les pages de ce format là mon
intime conviction mais après c'est une
conviction c'est rien de plus c'est
qu'ils souhaitaient
créer un genre de circuit parallèle il y
avait son championne sourd à côté il
avait son site avait beaucoup
d'investisseurs et beaucoup d'argent et
tout ce truc là a fait un énorme flop
mais à mon avis c'était fin c'était pas
dans il pensait pas faire un flop sinon
il n'aurait pas dépensé des millions
d'euros dans leur truc donc je pense
qu'ils sont dit on va faire un circuit
parallèle on a plein d'argent machin et
où l'on pourra se passer du cycle de
champion du monde et il se retrouve un
peu bloquée après avoir fait un flop as
hallucinant c'est magnifique
et
et du coup ils se retrouvent un peu
entre deux quoi je pense était pas son
plan initial
enfin peu importe non mais c'est
maintenant c'était ma conviction à
l'époque elle est que renforcée par ce
qui vient de se passer a battu à sion
qui s'était pas créé mon sens il a créé
un circuit à côté cirque l'internet avec
à tourner à part moi qui étais sur toute
une saison et
et donc oui il y avait eu une tentative
de quelque chose qui a fait un bide
impressionnant
mais pas dans le bon sens le bide
malheureusement d'ailleurs pour les
échecs parce que ça aurait bénéficié à
tout le monde que ça marche pour la
peine
mais oui ça ça habille des
saab idée
j'ai dit que le chef chez sable c'était
pas la folie et qu'ils avaient licencié
la moitié de leur effectif ong vu sa
muse aussi et ça fait aussi partie du
groupe manu ce donc oui peut-être que du
coup ça change aussi les perspectives
quant tout ton groupe on n'est pas dans
les comptes encore que les comptes sont
publics mais moi je n'ai pas étudié leur
compte mais c'est vrai que quand tu dit
quand tu licencie la moitié des
effectifs ça veut dire que ça marche pas
trop quoi a priori jamais revu
après c'est du rhin les échecs c'est une
économie spécial quand même c'est pas
facile hein de 30 avant les échecs tu
abuses un peu
ils ont licencié en oeuvre personne n'y
peut rien
c'est pas
parce que c'est à dire assez juste un
fait en fait et c'est pas y'a pas de
quoi se réjouir
non loin de là mais c'est juste que
c'est difficile d'économies dans les
échecs
en fait il ya eu un gros boum avec le
queens gambeat
et puis et puis et puis ça s'est passé
assez sévèrement ce dont je parle est un
dès janvier 2021 j'avais un peu
malheureusement vu si l'avenir
mais à
[Musique]
ça pas été
marrant que les autres spécialistes du
marché et pas anticipé
étonnant quand même parce que c'était
quand même enfin pour moi c'était une
évidence mais après
saison de prêt alors déjà ça j'ai jamais
vu de si quelqu'un juste moi j'aime
l'inversé en fait justement saison 2
jamais mais même ça avait une saison 2
en fait ça a déjà dégoûté les gens ce
qui se passe maintenant donc je pense
pas que les genres fin à la saison 2 ça
fera jamais le buzz de la saison à c'est
impossible
ça fera peut-être même pas de boss du
tout pour les échecs d'ailleurs
oms que même date fixe - du tout faire
quoi oui oui non mais ça fera un petit
quelque chose mais pas énorme
tout cas moi j'ai vu l inverse un cri
vous laisserons pas faire de saab et non
pas du tout prévue en fin de saison 2
c'est pas du tout dans les tuyaux
alors si carreaux ici à la tenir
bon certes nabeul mais ouais sorte
colonne c'est quoi un petit quelque
chose pour les blancs
tout accès à la casse et c'est un grand
honneur pour stargate pour faire un jour
un cahier betis qui est c4 mais tu auras
toujours tout un guerrier à 5 qui voient
interdire les petits éléments qui font
que tu as des trucs des qui tracasse d53
détour c'est cet attentat sega qui comme
nous y aura pas de saison 2 c'est sûr
facile de discuter avec des gens qui on
va pas le dff news
tout cas c'est pas annoncés on aura
peut-être une un jour mais pour le
moment là la volonté semble est de ne
pas en faire une deuxième
série nul aujourd'hui quand on sait pas
ça joue ça crie qu'un
se passe pas grand chose ça vous cliquez
très longtemps ce genre de truc où tu
manoeuvre inventif f4 avec les blancs à
noter en c4 tu repars tu reviens tu
vends effet inchangé trois tunnels des
rêves c'est un copain il se prépare à
faire j'ai quatre siècles et blanc crème
avec son rachat intervient plein de
choses ont été faites par le passé pour
attirer du monde de finale ça l'est
passion du jeu qui ne sont pas légions
continuons par mois je conjugue donc
rien n'a été fait pour a pour conserver
les gens
qui rapport même rouach un tour g1
de vue krikor ferait
ch 4 écoute ça va être intéressant même
si ça joue plus pour rien
et n'est pas tant voilà partis sur un
article
je sais pas comment on est tombé dessus
du coup des poteaux d'arrêt par contre
on à la partie
basse est toujours chaud je ne sais pas
personne je trouve que c'est parfois pas
plus mal une série top qui s'arrête à la
saison passée de série top qui se sont
partis en c'est au bout de la saison n
c'est un classique une saison début et
une fin moi j'aime bien oui ou non non
mais c'est je suis d'accord avec cet
accord avec toi ray ya trop de trop de
séries en fait qui sont faites pour
faire une saison en fait merde ça marche
bien ça tant mieux ça marche bien et du
coup tu signes pour refaire d'autres
trucs mais tu qu'on sache des éléments
aient pu être cohérent et à faire durer
pour faire durer et tu gâches en fait on
oeuvre alors la casa del papel
par exemple ça deviendra plus déprimant
n'importe quoi
mais pas que quoi en plein de trucs oui
la grèce de papel par exemple c'était
spectaculaire mais c'est fini ou pas
d'ailleurs je crois pas si c'est fini
maintenant il ya la casa de papel de
corée mais c'est avec d'autres acteurs
et voilà qu'à n'avait pas m'être jamais
vu la fin alors pas la fin c'est de la
merde enfin j'ai pas se priver pour
les éléments grotesque n'y a pas une
saison qui se finit un peu à moitié il
ya encore un truc à habas oui mais ça
s'est arrêté en plein mieux viennent
suite et ça c est déjà là en plein
milieu tu comprenais que ça pouvait
passer n'importe quoi depuis très
longtemps mais là c'est sans l'air
attaqué notre banque
comme
[Musique]
prison break
saison sympa il s'échappe et puis les
pressions la nature là bas du cou de
l'effet continu et puis battu les
renferme en prison c'est comme ça l'idée
qui s'échappe de prison ils sont en asie
ils sont chez paou fin ça devient
n'importe quoi c'est
walking dead est pareil ça l'a un peu
loin encore que
dans friends soutien de 10 saisons elles
se suivent bien battu longtemps à ce
papa il va se gardent la même personnage
tu fais évoluer leur vie ils ont des
enfants ils divorcent se mettent
ensemble souhaitent plus ensemble bon
c'est la vie quoi
fresnes c'était pas mal je veux dire un
truc à suspense est pas fait pour durer
mille ans quoi
et ouais soir le voit la saison 3 et
j'ai regardé le début après j'ai lâché
je suis bon là il a quatre qui est parti
j'ai pas vu mais oui la 3g - mais déjà
la une au dessus de tout fantastique
temps
après c'est une incohérence instant rien
c'était parfait
deux c'est déjà compliqué là trois
shows quoi et l'a4 a prouvé sa part bien
après la tuerie comment vas tu évoques y
voit sa série voit tout mais comment il
fait enfin il voit tout mais c'était
d'experts français ils pourraient ils
pourraient être faire un podcast ou quoi
mais à trois c'est là qu'ils avaient
l'ordinateur machin
autour des ordi mais l'intelligence
artificielle supérieur jeu parce qu'il
faudrait il ya vincent cassel dans les
trois mois il y avait le décès pinkman
aussi
chez passons d'acteurs paul quelque
chose croît
savoir si je suis en train de j'ai
commencé la quatrième saison hier mais
je suis endormi instante malheureusement
ron paul
on arrête ça pourrait partir en une ce
qu'on a de 12 ans témoin resté sur
revient sur mac a lancé la seule partie
il ya un petit temps je voudrais juste
là nul enfin pas attendre juste cliquer
les coûts de l'ennui
je pense pas que ce soit à cliquer nul 1
à la plainte en fait
ces chaudes comme progressiste à tour
bientôt reprendre des sept à dix coups à
paris qu'en mai
2004 24 et à tous de finale à key west
ham petites séquences à trouver quoi ça
marche
soprano c'est bien mais je n'ai pas vu
the wire il paraît que c'était bien que
j'ai pas vu non plus pendant la vie ces
rixes ont pas mal
six feet under
je pense que ça peut se regarder
toujours maintenant ça pas parti en
janvier
bien d'accord
expert série
quand il fait froid autant de séries les
regarde quand il fait tourner leur dis
mais les séries à côté il fait les deux
en même temps moi je crois en faudrait
demander son secret mais
je crois qu'il fait des trucs comme ça
et quand ils voient les séries s'occupe
d'eux des margoulins peu d'une oreille y
regarde d'un oeil 10 enfin il
al'expérience avoir concédé scène
jetables ou contre ce faux être faut
être à l'affût
quand il fait ce qui fait quand même
plein de trucs dans une journée mathieu
se joignent donc pas 24 heures
voilà rider pas vrai
chan
a pris la paf et snk de boeuf en scène
car il faut
si je crois qu'il a concédés titan sais
plus je crois qu'il a fait les titans
qu'elle n'est pas à fond devant les
épisodes mais ils cliquent un peu au
hasard
mais le fait
même il a même fait saine car cjga l'on
en fait après -100 kg beaucoup dormi du
coup après il faut un certain moment il
m'a manqué d'ereffe
et la ligue
en janvier avec ce soir la fin on anime
enfin j'espère que les choses changent
la fin ils peuvent arif ont souvent moi
j'espère vraiment que les radios les
quatre also vont voyager et il est mon
frère on avait tu pour les colossaux à
fond fuyez glaris je pense
que les colossaux doivent écraser le
monde
ça me paraît logique en fait j'ai pas
assez logique elles sont beaucoup plus
forts en plus tu te dis quand tu les as
raté
bah ouais enfin c'est tout partie parce
qu'ils sont venus le faire chier en fait
fin tant pis
ah non mais il est pas méchant et rennes
bah c'est pas que j'aime pas les humains
en fait je pars du principe que
ils sont venus le faire chier puis on va
juste il répond qu enfin
je sais pas ce que tu pense pareil non
sans parce qu'il est fait c'est une cape
en douter que c'est compliqué qu'il ya
les gentils et les méchants tu comprends
très bien les motivations des uns des
zoos harry qui font des conneries qu'il
n'a jamais hésité à se mettre d'accord à
faire des compromis ou quoi et c est bon
bah ça fini
c'est fini comme çà oui enfin oui mais
je veux dire qu'en fait et rennes il en
est pas du tout responsable non
non vous promet ce qui fait quoi
s'il le fait pas en fait ils vont lui
faire de l'éradication doute marine en
fait c'est tout sont tous ses potes sa
patrie tout ça qui va être exterminés
donc pas de choisir entre toi et risque
de se terminer les autres vous dommage
qu'ils aient pas un moment peut-être une
manière de t'expliquer dire tiens juste
mieux on extermine personne mais bon on
comprenne si on doit en arriver là c'est
waouh c'est moi et je préfère vivre au
moins à quoi fin
mais du coup ça fait bien la boucle
passait pas machiavélique comme c'est
bien en fait
malgré moi ce que j'aime pas trop c'est
que les autres ils se mettent d'accord
une fois qu'ils sont en position de
faiblesse
le choix mais en fait de mal ils ont
quand même voulu exterminer
irène quoi
je sais pas après on peut voir le truc
dans l'autre sens aussi un
manic 1 j'ai dit quoi tu as dit
machiavélique un oui manichéen cuir noir
ou blanc
vive le dernier cas
mais en fait je suis impression qui le
met au pied du mur
il est plus mûr
je sais pas mais j'ai l'impression que
[Musique]
il se retrouve à avoir la responsabilité
d'un truc horrible alors que
[Musique]
la pousse à le faire en fait hein mais
surtout on voit le tournant c'est quand
il écoute les discussions dont il est
une sorte de parlement la hausse et qui
voit qu'en fait il faut les exterminer
ils vont aller ouais c'est ça j'ai
compris à tous vous faire [ __ ] je
devrais je prendre mes responsabilités
mais
à quel point la désespérée de la
victoire donné posent sachant qu'il n'a
pas bouclé il en a absolument rien à
[ __ ] je pense globalement
au départ la chute du mur maria ça à
cause de ceux de l'extérieur bah oui
c'est bien ça l'huile est pour rien a
fallu et tranquille il joue avec ses
copains et voir sa mère tout ça puis je
fais bouffer quoi donc un moment
je pense tu fais une psychanalyse de
voir ta mère se faire bouffer quand tu
es petit tu as un titan john deere mon
soin de marquer quoi
bein
meta même et enfin moi je trouve qu'il
est vraiment pieds nus en fait pour
apporter encore sacrifié alors
s'attendait h quatre noms ouais
mais les prix de reprise dans le sens
mais ça revient même nom
de calais france et 4 d'abord je sais
pas quoi ça sert juste le fait je
comprends pas dans quel monde tu as
assez pas non plus mais pas dans love
john callas ici donne déjà égalé
mon fric fou et cette fois ci c'est le
truc de leurs 10 apparaît qu enfin
évidemment c'est jamais facile à trouver
mais si ta sagesse que c'est quasi
abandon je me tiens f8 une borne sat
avec le roi du court mais je sais pas ce
qu'il veut faire un jeu
et
les attend gaia et riga des dingueries
de partout
à un avis sur les cinq dossiers aux
abats j'aime pas j'aime pas trop la
structure qui est pas arrivé ouais
ça va faire ça ça ouais tu vas faire
[ __ ] que ces cinq tonnes métriques à
un sabre et mathieu la raison on sert
montrer dans toutes les écoles de
stratégie est rare typique
ouais ça c'est typique position que tu
peux avoir en cours niveau 1500 2000 f5
genre à mon niveau montre plus ce genre
d'exercice
pas je veux dire que puis on prend qui
les prend tous française mais en fait je
n'ai même pas réfléchi après peut-être
que avec son soutien à avoir de
l'activité je sais pas quoi mais ça a
pas l'air enfin c'est
juste là vraiment pas bon
c'est sûr que ça va pas après comme
c'est un bon joueur qui ses calculs
peut-être que la tenir mais sans mettre
les blancs vous n'êtes pas grand chose
jusque là j'avais dit que ce soit d'une
longue man'ok préparé quatre faire j'ai
quatre mains rapporte
je sais pas mais il va se passer des
choses quoi on sait ce qu'a dit j'ai
réécouté guiry aussi que la pose de
trois trucs en fait il disait en gros
que firent vous déjà le problème ce qui
veut tout le temps pour gagner et on
sait très bien qu'on des joueurs à 2602
ce qui les dominent largement en fait là
ça va pas du tout en fait il va falloir
qu'il apprenne à jouer pour nulle
ces derniers jours deux positions rien
faire et pas tout le temps
à la fin rien que c'est stratégiquement
dégueulasse on
le problème c'est qu'en fait c'est très
simple ça sert de cible et tu fais une
partie il faut rien faire et fera pas
rien
et du coup tu peux le cueillir
donc l'ordi vous l'a priori g5 web à
jessains que tu veux faire mes droits je
ne sais pas si c'était si forget est ce
un coupable mais
ouais tu touches plus bas tu vas me
ramène qui revient aux 6,9
ouais bah là il va souffrir american va
être très bien implanté petit à petit il
va prendre là je pensais apprendre ces
cinq ça me laisse sur
le cas de dire est que sa police sa tête
un
échange surprendre de la f3 tu fait
tordre et un tuyau la majorité j'ai pas
attendre un f5 qu'il faut prendre 500 a
été mon premier réflexe mais ça
en fait j'ai juste pour une scène qui
aurait envie mais
en fait pour jouer sur les cases
blanches d'euros je sais que tout cas ce
soir
mais c'est vrai cette séquence là les
instantanés normalement site à cette
position en cours ta trung qui lève la
main après 10 secondes
mais il a des belles lacunes 1 en fait
ça qui est dommage aussi avec cramique
parce que c'est dans ce qu'il dit n'a
pas forcément tort mais c'est un peu
comme magnus il a raison dans le fond
mais il a tellement de tort dans la
forme que ça va pas c'est la même faille
dire que c'est marrant parce que le les
déclarations cette semaine que ce soit
de magnus août cramique je trouve que
les deux ont vraiment à chaque fois
raison dans le fond mais la forme est
tellement horrible que en fait ils ont
tort
enfin le russe n'est pas l'histoire de
forme pour annexer qui ne doit pas
parler de son élève oui mais jamais dans
will à l'horizon sur ce qu'il dit voir
sa position à lui peut pas lire et c'est
comme ça il a raison de vouloir chute de
réformer le format du championnat du
monde mais c'est pas l'homme mais c'est
pas le bon cheval pas évident il n'y a
rien qui va est en fait c'est bête parce
qu'enfin c'est dommage parce que le sag
h le propos ça gâche tellement de propos
enfin c'est juste des choses que tu peux
pas faire dans les deux cas c'est
dommage
ils sont courants rapporté que les
prochains candidats vont jouer
partiellement alé lô pourquoi tenter un
taux qui sert à rien et sacrifier des
points là-bas écoute ça j'en sais rien
lorsque la cause je suis d'accord avec
toi mais après quand j'en ai parlé hier
sur la il ya plein de gens qui me sont
tombés dessus fab on est le témoin pour
dire oui mais c'est beaucoup mieux que
vous qui voulez faire vos petites tenues
ils ont du panache mais oui enfin t'as
du pana a juste eu donne des punto choix
c'est on est d'accord ça sert absolument
à rien et mais je sais pas en fait
pourquoi ils font ça c'est inexplicable
c'est juste des mauvais choix mais faire
très attention ne pas le dire ici on
pouvait te dire tu n'aimes pas les mêmes
pas les échecs
tu as tellement de gens qui m'ont écrit
ça depuis une semaine
je n'aime vraiment pas les échecs jeu
très négatif
le plus beau que jamais eu mais c'était
pas cette fois-ci sky mais il fait
vraiment beaucoup de mal aux français
pour l'honneur ouais mais en fait il ya
peut-être une heure à s'envoyer en l'air
en fait c'est par un shonen les échecs
j'ai publiquement ce jour que tu
secondaire probablement en fait ils ont
dû avoir un dessin on imagine on n'en
sait rien mais ils ont dû avoir un gros
d ailleurs vous êtes ensemble c'est
probablement fait virer et il fait une
crise d'ego quoi
est-ce que l'on va se suppose toujours
avec lui et que tu dis ça publiquement
et non là c'est pas possible ça sent pas
trop donc et un truc à moi je passais
organique de 10 postes ici ça il n'a pas
fait j'en sais rien en fait enfin je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé du tout on
dans les hypothèses mais c'est sûr
qu'ils ont travaillé ensemble
après quoi qu'il en soit à pas dire ça
maintenant où tu le dit différemment dit
bonbons notre un moment et après le
tournage remarquer qu'il ya des
faiblesses j'essayais de me corriger bon
a priori je suis pas que vous trouvez à
faire ce que je devais ou bien un truc
comme ça
mais pas juste à dire jeter la faute
dessus complètement mais je suis à peine
à 2300 famille
n'a rien dit sur performance à les
couvents se sont pas hyper intéressante
s'expédier
après la ce genre d'erreurs stratégiques
ans vient de faire alireza ça me paraît
fou parce que j'ai vraiment l'impression
que j'ai appris ce genre de chose quand
j'avais 11 ans 12 ans je sais pas quel
âge mais oui face à ses fins c'est
ridicule quoi apprendre en
reste et du cavalier henri iv
indéboulonnable
on n'a pas ça parce qu'on va cependant
clouage
perdu donc je préfère notre coup et puis
bah petit à petit blond aussie de
travail et après je vous dis pas qu'ils
vont gagner à coup sûr mais en fait tu
l'as déjà c'est du jas de résultat
est plus sain que l'autre mais
on est comme ça on attend français 5
n'était pas obligé de fermer ça te donne
vraiment tellement envie
mais après fear oui la tête le même
problème un peu connais peut-être qu'il
arrive juste plus à jouer 1 mais bon le
truc c'est un truc que disait vas tu
sais qu'en fait tu peux excuser des
pièces donnant et comme faisait dépôt
mais des erreurs comme ça en fait ne se
laisse pas faire en fait
juste eu peut pas la menthe empêche
et us et fabien quand on parle de main
qui empêche
pas obligé d'avoir un petit vlad
ambulant un
chauffard l'autre vainqueur touche
propre chef
et c'est dans les deux sens c'est à dire
d'un côté qu'il a un énorme talent et
qui peut avec de telles lacunes il
arrivé tellement haut que son talent et
cosmique et d'un autre côté tu as la
question entre guillemets inverse avocat
du diable est ce qu il peut juste et
c'est bizarre sourit j'ai pas souvenir
de l'ordre et des trucs comme ça avant
peut-être que les autres je m'étais pas
les positions pour
arriver enfin à toi que tu entendes un
choix à faire a tancé espagnole contre
carl zeiss et pas c'était pas bon mais
on faisait bon se passer comme ça non
mais peut-être que nous on fait
mais du coup il a une grosse marge de
progression donc ça c'est excellent
après est ce que il n'avait pas une
lacune l' énorme qui est pas qu il ait
pas possible de corriger parce que ça
convient pas à son intelligence ou j'en
sais rien moi tu vois particulier les et
chacun
qui va calculer méga bits mais que mais
que ça il peut pas pour une raison x ou
y faire face on n'est pas bon dans tout
un nom mais le truc enfin juste fournir
la partie donné raison à m
donc fait il a paniqué et je pense
bon il a fait français 5 en fait ici il
a vu où on soit ça soit ça ça et l'autre
qui revient en f1
ou des f4 et en fait je voulais pas quoi
faire contre enfin peut-être c'est steve
est trop écrasée à long terme ce qui
n'est pas vraiment le cas mais il a
sous-estimé surestimé les blancs et du
coup il s'est dit ok jazz dynamique
mais en fait je vois pas le dynamisme
problème c'est que tu te fous des
problèmes à long terme irréversible
tu fais pas de menace en fait
donc dur
est-ce qu'il doit pas sur les conseils
de double of
the cove juste faire de la littérature
vire tranquille
fait de voir filer une théorie
mais qui est pas débile c'est quand même
site a absolument aucune culture autour
des échecs tout ça te limite
de la culture vient enfin je serai en
fait non c'est pas mais en fait ils te
disent lido safe qui lie nabokov très
important quoi arrête le bol à être un
juste et 10 tolstoï et peut-être
peut-être
pourquoi nabokov schepp a
ensuite précède deux doubles un
mois j'avais vu la récente journée
pareille qui avait la liste des 100
livres à lire dans l'avis
est en fait vient de siffler quatre
livres par an je veux ni en fait ni
retourner pour 25 ans et
deux jours à travers des chèques à ce
moment là mais bon je serai plus tout
jeune quoi est ce qu'il a dit à kariat
qui en fait c'est a manqué pour aller
plus haut
t'as pas lu de saut à skis non mais
comment tu veux bien jouer aux échecs
t'as pas lu de sa fille
mais je sais pas si ça apporte ou pas
mais enfin je trouve que c'est pâques ou
en fait non mais c'est pas contrefaçon
d'avoir autre chose est
de saut à skis quoi tu es là tu as toi
tu fais moins du bullet
ce que je lis des cendres non mais tu la
clique sur internet à l'isra quoi est ce
qui est adossé à skis dedans peut-être
même plus à vif qui a je vais regarder
il ya quelques temps j'ai pas content
mais je vais le faire en tient peut-être
là dans les semaines à venir verne
acheter un et je vais le lire pendant
l'été
mais bon j'espère trouver sur un livre
qui se lit bien que c'est un truc trop
dur pour moi ah les frères karamazov
aucun lien fils unique
cherche sa liste
camus déjà j'ai lu bravo
bon il ya 4,4 fois dostoïevski c'est
l'auteur le plus représenté donc tu vois
comme quoi double au filet quand même il
y connaît un rayon il ya trois kafka 3
shakespeare et 3 tolstoï
non mais d'où beauf en fait c'est c'est
du sucre on veut être ok juste écoute du
beauf et tu vas juste appel du beauf et
tu lui demandes je lis quoi
à le père goriot
balzac vos livres
via le vieil homme et la mer non
j'espère c'est un de mes livres et fait
don quichotte jamais lu mais
présente don quichotte j'en ai pas vu
beaucoup un
wet à dos f kita crime et châtiment
l'idiot les démons les frères karamazov
avoisine les angolaises caudillo
dostoïevski en fait vous êtes comprend
200 poids lourds
au madame bovary flaubert magnifique
fable je vais peut-être le l'éducation
sentimentale important
nous avons aussi un petit chez pas trop
surtout lycée collège
à le violer la mer wayne hemingway mère
incroyable
je veux bien me croit
bellamy lalami c'est magnifique je mets
ses mots passants non
bbc flaubert g + 7 mois passant belani
je tapais pouvoir d'achat
rivalis maupassant j'ai senti
guy de maupassant
louis
murat sacchi chikhi bout le dit du genji
suis pas prêt à me replacer à parler de
ce truc eve l'avenir my mind nabokov
lolita moon et siad pas mal dans leur
lycée que il ya plusieurs périodes et
plusieurs régions et puis enfin tu vois
c'est pas oui oui un peu de tout ça se
ressente pas mal de par contre rabelais
gargantua et pantagruel oui oui ça
aille à masnaa vie de djalal abad dinner
au mit jet ça extraordinaire comme le
recommande
non mais bon un gargantua et pantagruel
c'est de la merde
ils sont très heureux non mais géré
c'est bien mais bon enfin
guerre et paix
chimiste s'agit lui
je ne viens pas locaux et des petites
lectures tranquille où
j'ai bien vu le prophète aussi dans les
trucs dans ce genre là
oui c'est léger c'est déjà lassés de
vivre
tu as diderot jamais lu jacques le
fataliste et son maître
je sais même pas que ça existait
pas du stendhal non
voyage au bout de la nuit c'est céline
je pense j'ai lu ce n'est beau que celui
dont la caméra
ouais je pense
vazimba un tour de stade
car on est très bien du coup
[Musique]
bon je vais m'arrêter là pour ce tournoi
je me contenterai année youtube pour la
fin merci messieurs en tout cas pour
l'avoir rendue beaucoup moins chiant que
ce qu'il aurait été sans vous écoute
merci à toi ce jeune
n'est pas il a trouvé wave acquis qu'il
faut des cinq a priori
nakta ding ok bon
écoute je suis pas comment il va
attaquer garda de prendre un petit coup
de chaud richie mais bon
le livre est en général abbas et le
livre de rûmî qui est hyper connue c'est
un auteur connu verse pour la peine
peut-être alireza la lutte pour la paix
c'est ce qui arrive dostoïevski aussi un
mérou me je pense que c'est un auteur
perse
voie sûre qu'il partit alors adding d'un
cas parce que ça joue pour quelque chose
genre d'échec
jeunes
ses trois enfants roms nantes une place
vous faire re six
essais 5 et chaque
client
bref
1984 bien aussi important
ces masses navy qui recommanderait de
deux-roues me
un truc comme ça mais
bon c'est pas encore
encore fini tout ça
une petite sur animer des dingueries de
parts et d'autres je faisais ça le f5 il
est exceptionnel quand même c'est rare
d'état le faux attentat le niveau mais
j'ai cinq pareil en fait j'ai un accès
plus tactique mais je veux qu'on veut ce
qu'il veut
mais oui 84 très bon livre
le second avec un
point qui fait que
durer longtemps avec des trous partout
complexe fab
et à vue sur le château de mon père les
jaguars de mon père j'ai vu des films
c'était bien les films oui
moi non plus je n'ai pas lu mais
important
de marcel pagnol je crois que c'est un
troisième fois ci on a trois ouais
mais pagnol wells c'est du génie vrai
c'est dommage qu'ils aient pas écrit en
provençal ses livres comme mistral qui
écrivent en provençal cette chance qui
les a écrits en français n'ont pas ni à
droite jean
virus régions de la france manon dit à
l'époque
sympa
ministre a loué et puis il écrivait en
provençal
était très déçu lui qu'on lui après le
français à l'école il comprenait pas
trop
ils te disent eh ben j'ai aucun rapport
prend mal en quoi
je pense c'est est une
une envie un moment d'éliminer les
patois
langues régionales
manon sens du vent de mer notre humeur
on s'est un peu tard a eu il comprenait
pas trop quoi il je suis un romain
on a braqué gaulle enfin
l'architecturé plutôt plutôt romaine
catalyseur dans sa ville thatta des
arènes romane pudibonds
ya eu débat très sûr qu enfin
l'alcool des artistes
mais c'est bon quoi il s'était fait un
petit musée entre anthropologique je
pense
peut-être anthropologique
à part avec le moïse mais c'est pas
assez plu non
c'est pas possible mais bon il est très
heureux de culture provençale
le niveau cinq sets
surmonter la douleur
l'a facilement remporté le troisième le
cinquième francs suisses 3 il a du
succès annoncé de ses deux breaks 6
il était blessé
mais du coup il va pas
bien
les frites saucisses et qualifié
la frite veut aller en finale
20 18 heures c'est l'heure la nouvelle
pub mon fab petite pause
ok peut-être un petit nul 1 qui arrive
six food et 6 kg 4
voilà ok tout à l'heure à la la
yoyo non
alors cette finale
entre dingana
kg passé passé grand chose on va faire
un petit tour des stades rick est parti
d un rapport radjabov bon rapporte tente
de monter une attaque
bon on verra il a
un pion pour la pièce sacrifiés
enfin mais bon je sais pas il met la
pression quoi s'attendre on baissa dame
locale à revenir
qui sait truc là un truc là bon ok à
voir
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres
on a donc dignac à ça on a déjà vu rien
de suspect
caruana avec aaron assez
étonnant quoi c'est étonnant d'avoir
enlevé la faiblesse adverse
et
edouard me
fous du coup il est plus si dégoûté quoi
après montre qu'il est bien placé
évidemment il touche pas mal de casse du
fou mais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans votre rôle
est radin goisbault beaucoup plus
logique je suis d'accord c'est à dire
que les blancs ballet final voit de
bonnes donc un truc comme dame eu trois
balles et on passe le coup je sais pas
je m'en fous dame là on peut on a envie
pour la finale mais on peut pas parce
qu'on va perdre le pion à f2 donc on
doit le défendre
kiev 3 ou un petit roi g2 j'en sais rien
mais bon on va dire qu'on ait fait froid
avant premier tour f3 et ensuite on a un
truc comme ça manque le roi en mai la
dame est à petit à petit on va
travailler la position parce qu'en plus
on va pouvoir placer ici attaque et ça m
une tour henri iv peut-être
ya de quoi faire ok donc que roanne a
fait un truc très très bizarre
ouais bah écoute on est parti à l'ewf
après l'ont peut-être qu'il veut je
goûte le roi un peu faible évidemment il
ya deux options devant lui dont celui-là
qui est ici donc un skate c'est de
mettre en place un truc comme ça mais
bon le pouvoir tourner ici
web on a plutôt peut-être faire f 4 ont
d'ailleurs on se libérer on va voir bon
ok c'est plus si claire du coup alors
qu'il avait un très très bon avantage et
doudane et pau
nous donne est posée cette finale cette
finale la hongrie vol de coups joués on
était comme ça fout des 5 c'est bien
joué vous
semblez 6 propose les changes je
m'attends à ce que peut-être garde les
tours l'a pas fait
et on est comme ça ok bah
ça te conduire vers la nuit là après
qu'il eut ni la double attaque france à
france à
la voile a
bon a priori ça ça simplifie n'iront
nulle en simplifie néant nul il ya de
bonnes chances il ya de bonnes chances
que ça nul comme ça ok
bon bah du coup on voit à peu près ce
qu'il se passe quoi et on va retrouver
chez big mac adam kennedy c'est un peu
la partie qui jouent pour la seconde
place
et digne car elle qu'on va faire des
choses dans la position ça partait de
loin oui c'est pas c'est pas grand chose
mais cette petite tour en 17 c'est pas
mal
un hacker alain kouck hathaway mahfoud
élite c'est pas très bon tour des huit
tours des huîtres etc si les blancs on
veut le garder les tours il va s'activer
peut-être lui venir prendre ça où tout
cas si on chasse le cavalier apprendre à
tour du tour des deux attaques et ici
donc ouais et s'il est blanc décide
d'échanger de se laisser changer gens ça
alors on a envie de venir alors faire
gaffe au calice et 5 c'est parce qu'il
eut peur d'un truc
et ont même cassé s'inquiète des weppes
à
l'ordi 10 si je fais ça ils diffusent
cette sas
hockey même ça ça peut faire peur quand
même pas
aujourd'hui sont fouillés mais 00
bon moi je vois ça je comprends pas
qu'ils 00 fait
peut-être qu'il veut te dire tu vas pas
facilement faire un truc la balle
rétroactif que on va bloquer ou
peut-être que lui va sauter après ouais
ouais avec lui quand même on a un pion
de moins mais pas pour longtemps
bon ok
ménaka du coup je sais pas l'aval du
juge et le truc il a fait food et 8 donc
c'est vrai qu'il va supporter est
toujours pas si on compare les deux
tours celle là qu'on va mettre tour
forte envers une tour pour rien en rouge
nos différences
une grosse différence
il
le plant pour être ça et ça va venir on
se rapproche après vers ce g7 j'aime pas
trop les options de macquarie
vraiment écouté on va voir on va voir
mes vrais fous des huit
étapes et la route
on a vu les quatre sinon
un truc car on a fait un truc bizarre
rapport est facile contre je doute
années pose ça devrait faire une bientôt
et on est là ok on va voir zagg maca est
moins tranquille que
que tout à l'heure dallas a été relaxé
sur son fauteuil tranquille il buvait
son coca et son starbucks en même temps
là tout d'un coup
pas même posture digne par contre on
tour rien lire ainsi pokerface l'homme
de marbre
ok ben non ils arrivent ils arrivent
mais bon comme ça leur arrive avant moi
on se relaie un peu pour le solo
oui car
cette plateforme sera pas non plus fin
j'étais tellement content mon autre
avantage que j'aurai aussi de travailler
avant de le changer mais ça me fait
penser des fois
je sais pas je vois que c'était moustaki
et nous a montré une de ces parties
quand je récupère montpellier dans une
française qui a aidé 2 tu arraches des
eaux des deux pions isolé
moment il fait un plomb avec les bains
il fait ses quatre donc ils enlèvent le
pion aux rides et noir ont fait un truc
tout symétrique mais il avait pièce
mieux placé est atteint et ce avec ses 4
c'est pas naturel du coup d'enlever à
faiblesses adverses et donc ceux des
cats de 46 et c'est pas pareil même dans
l'esprit quoi ça me fait penser à ça
ok donc d'un cas qui a envoyé quatre
alors c'est quoi l'idée si je bouffe
l'ordi dis ça juste un truc pourquoi tu
as besoin de faire f 4 et il fait pas ça
direct s'est fait attaquer lui et du
coup je préfère attaquer avoir des pions
doublé échos perdre ça et si tu fais ça
trous partout est ok c'est la cata ça on
entend ce qui se passe très bien donc ok
alors il fait 4 donc si vous voulez
faire ça
ok qui est des quatre admettons qu'ils
aillent prince cinq cavaliers lors
des belles pièces
ça va peut-être
f5 pas le coup de rein de l'ordi mais
bon
j'aime pas beau le bien
est ce que ça va gagner je sais pas mais
un droit qui peut monter par là bas en
passant par là disons ça c'est un plan
la tour super lui mal placé qui est mal
d'éléments qui font plaisir pour les
blancs ne prêche pas ca sert évidemment
mais ça peut être un truc comme ça la
partie mis d'accord j'ai on a compris le
f4 du coup il veut dans espion pour
aller ce danger là et se dire ok je
défends ce g7 à fond mais il perd pas
siffler
non inégal mais quand il a bien joué il
a bien joué non mais en fait en gros il
a il arrivé très tard qu'ont ils à la
veille ou l'avant-veille donc quand tu
viens de chine tu as un bon décalage
horaire dans la tête il l'a pas
directement
s'est pas mis directement dedans et il a
galvaudé des positions gagnantes dans la
pratique du tournoi une avec les noirs
comptent radjabov une avec les blancs
contre contrat porte phase retour il a
beaucoup mieux joué il a vraiment bien
joué en fait de la joie son niveau bien
pour il a fait une partie de merde
contre compte radjabov mais à part ça il
a tellement chez les gars on a fait
trois d'affilée ou quoique bon l'un dans
l'autre
très bonne phase retour on me fait
penser un peu au tennis quand tu
cravache
d'or
disperse passeur des choses
wes il se passe un peu des trucs ici ou
là alors qui en a fait un truc bizarre
tu va les voir
dinguerie
fait des cats 5
croyable non ouais j'aurais jamais fait
mais
bon va peut-être qu'il veut
il veut quoi je vais pas dire tiens
leurs adversaires plus faibles la
capture devant lui il veut faire f 4
mètres de quai à angers 5 je sais pas
mais oui j'aurais pas fait du tout
surtout connaissant fil rouge à quoi ils
allaient détester sa position faire
rager de f3 ça me trois danois c'est dur
un nom mais sa calandre il s'est quand
même
tu veux vont là où cela va faire un nul
ça c'est ça il est pas trop bien mais
quand même et ont rapporté all in mais
ça passe ou darchy tu te fout quoi
djadja 3e 3e ex-aequo 3 4e quoi c'est
fou hein bravo à lui un faire face à la
phase retour lui aussi il a été très bon
d'abord tu n'as qu'à l'habitude signé
il devrait battre rapporte aujourd'hui
donc ouais l'avait pas volé sa place aux
derniers candidats
radjabov
il a pris 24 hockey
je sais pas mais tout peut se passer
dans cette partie
chaque coup m'étonne en fait on veille
sur digne quand même ouais parce que ça
joue quand même la deuxième place comme
on disait c'est le dernier dernier chose
qui joue un truc
mais pourquoi leur dit et si catastrophe
et je comprends que c'est pas terrible
mais pas à la vente que je regardais
c'était genre ça bon tu as dont j'assure
h5 lire vient faire son tour va défendre
il va te faire ça marche pas maintenant
ou plus tard exact c'est quand même
chiant parce que oui voilà mais bon
après je tiens ton truc mais nuiront pas
si phare peut-être pas le temps de faire
sadr partir moi j'en sais rien de fait
on partira peut-être mais
ouais d'ailleurs j'aime bien que l'ordi
prophylaxie
c'est quand même pénible quoi près
peut-être tu peux être bat là-bas j'en
sais rien de compliqué
ouais en gros voilà
mais à huit championnats sont moins bien
pas tout le monde voit ça après je sais
pas à quel point c'est
meding plutôt dans son élément je pense
aux calculs et précis il est technique
parce que ça s'est joué
par six bouches du rhône est au final
voilà
la même nuit
je sais pas on leur dit à cinq voix pour
les noirs mais je retrouve expatriés des
camps
et
3,6 barton fait du g4
la saq des pions sur noir et mâcha il
doit réfléchir à ça en fait bon il a
priori pas ça met et il est réfléchi
avant garde vous bouffe a priori et leur
antre regarda culture et là bas vous
avez joué ça ça va du rhin pourri chaos
et a fait quatre il n'y a pas du tout
prix un f4
arrive 4 il faut pousser afin le 5e 6e
7e
jusqu'à aussi s'apprend
en
on verra
c'est très chaud hein ouais
tout cas c'est une belle partie non mais
en fait c'est incroyable que 1000 à
transformer le plomb en or congrès une
fois mais c'est précieux
rappelez vous c'était ça ou tout début
quoi
et en fait j'ai bien vu cette décision
ça c'est un truc que dans les livres de
bar de la colonne ouverte quoi parce que
tu gardes ta tour ici tu es tu appuies 1
à 4 tu as compris que la vraie colonne
c'est la colonne cette colonne des en
fait tu gères il tempéré c'est très bien
je sais c'est un groupe difficile je
crois que ça a joué et petit à petit il
a bâti son truc
c'est impressionnant quand je veux dire
au cas où c'est pas un plot non plus en
phase donc il a fait faux et 6 on sait
pas ce que leur dire comment des mais
bon je passe alors dit assez bien ici
d'une petite profondeur il ordi en fait
il voulait mettre le caillou 5 effet
rétro à d'abord essayé de bloquer comme
ça je sais pas de se balader
ok bon si je jouais n'y a pas une veste
à temps soit le coup mais elle n'est pas
à gagner le tournoi alors aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il fait nul mais où il a gagné
il va finir à 9 points et demi sur leurs
corps dans les candidats et
ils finiraient invaincu ce qui n'est pas
souvent le cas au candidat et américains
mais je crois qu'il ya eu diri quatre
ans et ding encore avant comme écrit à 4
ans sans gagner d ignorer que des nuls
mais un nombre 2014 way
minutes contre les pauvres n ont nul
contre n'est pas il aurait fait huit
ennemis mais pourrait quand même fini à
neuf il aurait quand même fini devant
même seeding l'avait pas battu après ça
aurait tout changé
oui je l'aï fait un hymne et un tel
écart
je rêve ou caruana à deux minutes et
demie pour jouer 11 coups du rêve je
rêverais
bombay l'art de la logique
moi
j'ai appris un petit et les quatre un
petit fou des quatre ans
car on a perdu mais ça me rappelle
complètement comment ils jouaient haut à
bucarest j'ai l'impression quand ils
jouent plus pour rien c'est pas du tout
de même à me caruana
mais là c'est grotesque de faire des 4
es ce que tu sais mais j'ai peut-être
s'il peut être des plombs je sais pas
enfin nostradamus demain non mais enfin
quand il s'arrête aujourd'hui on va
faire une vidéo et puis s'est terminée
en fait on les aura assez vu il y aura
pas de énième vidéo on peut mettre la
gamme de shekels en hurlant
sauf qu'on appelle wayne on me l'a pas
deux minutes trente pour onze coups là
très clairement c'est pas possible il
serait paru si calme vous s'en fout
celui-ci voit ici sony 14 minutes mais
géré là elle est très fragile alors une
série de coups de merde quoi
pas dix secondes pour jaune
pour revenir après un mais en gros
[Musique]
romeu séquence de caruana qui a gâché un
avantage stable à long terme pour faire
un truc où il fait peut être menacée et
mêmes en danger enfin d'avoir trouvé des
coûts pour stabiliser mais
mais voilà
on rappelle qu' à quelques coups ses
positions c'était ça il ya cinq coups en
fait
c'était juste tranquille tu peux ne rien
faire prendre ton temps et il a fait j 3
pour faire des quatre pour faire j'ai
pris un cas exceptionnel chaque coup ça
plonge quoi contresens à ses pétages de
plombs fatigue lassitude
oui mais manque d'enjeu à je veux dire
si tu veux pas d'enjeu a quand même eu
cette chance-là dans l'ouverture mais je
sais pas pris font pas de nul arrangeait
c'est merci tu envie de faire nul là on
n'avait pas eu d'annoncé mais ils
veulent pas et après il pète les plombs
perçoit fait nul ça joue bien mais f
passa combats n'ont fait que des nuls 1
si c'était nous mais oui
mais après moi j'ai pas envie de blâmer
les joueurs c'est pas facile de jouer
quand tu joues pour rien du tout c'est
dur en fait non on a tendu la perche
ouais c'est ici roja il est relou il
joue c'est truc fins telles que de base
il voulait jouer puis après il s'est
rendu compte que ça le faisait chier
j'en sais rien moi oui mais au pire là
tu fais rien et tu présentes dans 12
coups qu'on sera le 40e et je sais pas
des fois il pète les plombs je suis
d'accord avec toi mais je comprends pas
3500 euros dangereux quand même - ouais
mais il gagne un million par an donc
artifice
le toit est fait ça puis voilà mais
mieux en fait jamais si tu veux vraiment
pas joué je veux dire après je suis
d'accord avec toi je comprends pas mais
je pense à mon nez tu dois pété un plomb
de voir tellement marre de jouer aux
échecs c'est ce qui expliquait année
peau à peau car ils avaient beau
championnat du monde et les six majeur
parce que son cerveau voulait plus voir
des chèques en fait je pense c'est ça
qui se passe et conservant m'ont donné
ils saturent et tu te mets à faire des
choix
je veux pas blâmer les joueurs quoi
alors tourner sur votre grand format du
jour
[Musique]
tu vois bien que il enfin ils le disent
eux-mêmes en fait dans les interviews
c'est leur métier en fait c'est comme je
sais pas quel est ton métier mais est ce
que tu es content tous les jours d'aller
travailler non enfin euh c'est pareil
mais en plus tu peux être content de
jouer en général mais après quinze jours
enfin plus en fait trois semaines une
dernière partie sans enjeu
c'est dur en fait c'est dur mais joe
torre motivé chaque jour c'était un
métier normal en fait un métier normal
des fois tu vas travailler vite fait
parler qui collectent prend le café
enfin c'est pas obligé d'être à fond
quoi dans le sport de haut niveau
qu'est quoi c'était pas motivé l'autre
va l'attraper plate il ya de balayer
quoi
c'est dur en fait c'est
mélissa jour t'as pas trop envie de te
prennes courir on vas tu vas voir ça va
pas durer longtemps non c'est dur c'est
vraiment dur ce qu'ils font mais les
gens veulent pas le comprendre
c'est là que grâce à un effort j'ai un
sens qui peut être jamais les plans m es
tu vois justement il veut il veut pas
trop jouer il joue peu de tournage il en
joue moins que les autres globalement
déjà reçu qui peut aussi parce qu'il n'a
pas tous les toits de qualification et
les candidats et c'est donc il joue
moins et le truc qui n'aime pas jouer
c'est les championnats du monde qui ce
qui est dans un format ressemblant au
caron dida je suis pas sûr qu'ils aiment
en fait ça non ça c'est sûr qu'ils
aiment pas sûr qu'ils aiment pas en fait
donc fait vu que carl c n'aime pas le
championnat du monde je pense enfin j'en
déduis mais après j'en sais rien mais
qu'il aimerait pas trop les candidats
non plus
mais
metz a encore ouais je sais des gens
n'arrivent pas à le comprendre mais
pas plus car voilà alors de passer je
redis une fois encore de ça
ça en six coups
il doit se parler tout seul à dire
[ __ ] que j'ai foutu enfin là il prend
pas du plaisir bien sûr il est des peurs
les spas et tout seul dans sa tête à
dire des coûts coppens et c'est sur quoi
j'ai dix bobby fischer je savais pas
mais il disait détester les échecs à
haut niveau mais oui mon forcément si
l'art et essai qui l'aimé pas mais en
fait faut
bagasse il disait qu'il n'est pas le
tennis par exemple mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui aiment pas
en fait dans les gens qui jouent au
festival y en a qui adorent y en a qui
adore georges palet en tant que je pense
qu'il m par exemple mais ça dépend des
gens ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aiment les
haut niveau vu que traduit les
passionnés du jeu d'échecs mais la
compétition c'est particulier un bel
avion il ya une pression c'est papa et
d'aimer les échecs dans les es
tranquille chez toi de faire un petit
but de et d'aller subir cette pression
des parties vont durer huit heures et
ils disent radjabov c'est vrai il a fait
un petit burnout d échec certes signé
plusieurs années et puis les revenus
pour un tournoi il va probablement
repartir et c'est dur en fait allé
chercher non il y en a plein qui ouais
les joueurs chinois y en a plein qui ont
arrêté
laurent une pression en fait on
de bons exemples mais je pense est assez
commun dans les sportifs de haut niveau
de pas trop aimé ce qu'ils font mais ça
les empêche pas de le faire en fait
c'est pas
mais du coup là c'est dur après un
tournoi comme ça c'est long et ça peut
expliquer une mauvaise partie -
tours 8
c'est difficile
là bas il aime forcément leur sport mais
c'est juste qu'en faire tout le temps
avec une impressionnante ça fini par
dégoûter bah oui mais c'est enfin quand
tu fais du sport de haut niveau tu es
obligé d'en faire beaucoup pendant
longtemps ça votre genre t'as pas le
choix donc ça finit par te dégoûter
ouais mais c'est normal face et humains
et à la pression va jouer en compétition
aux jeux amical ça rien à voir aussi
quoi
en fait
et en compétition et des enjeux communs
pour un titre de champion du monde au
bout ou quoi c'est compliqué enfin
d'où la petite nul d'où la petite lionne
qui te soulage vif baddou dépôt est
celui qui a gagné celui qui a le plus
fait c'est une époque qui a fait le plus
de petit nul insipide et financé lui qui
gagne et qui va pas qui a pas forcé les
événements qui a pas fait partie de six
heures
épouse
si tu bouffes et la même chose tous les
jours ça va être très bon moment
j'aime bien le coût de leurs 10 ans
provocateur
walid et surtout reprend c'est qu'on va
faire une double attaque veulent y est
que sur ça tu vas faire kf5 j'imagine
srlf
5ème annoncé pas assez fort et heureux
cinq
attaques lui deux fois ci s'en va c'est
la tour et donc re deux sets mais juste
un coup qu'on peut ne pas envisager quoi
sert à rien car très vite ils attaquent
le pion qui tient debout flandre mettent
en échec mais ça évite bien ça super
coureuses ça peut se trouver mais
difficile surtout avec quatre minutes
pour un coût sans lustre de oui ça tu
vas en d3 cette fois c'est très
difficile
cette 40e ils le trouvent ces
magnifiques roi g2 fait un peu le tas de
paille mais j'aime mieux de plus souple
que les vrd 3,23 à plus de choix j'ai
deux petites limites dans tes choix dont
les deux ce joli coup
caro aussi en quelque sorte enfin il
aime les échecs mais gère la compétition
s'il a autant arrêter sous la main mais
d'heure il a dit en interview ça que ça
lui mettais trop de pression et que ça
me saoulait nicolas il joue mieux il est
allé dans mon coeur
mais un vrai met
donc en fait il ya beaucoup d'exemples
de joueurs
du servic es mis à eau des professions
qui font un genre doit genre de pain
c'est trop en fait ils ont peu influent
donc là ce truc-là plus la phase de
préparation plus les 13 parties avant tu
pètes des plombs quoi
panne et paul à 10 est en fête a plein
de joueurs qui le disent mais
un endroit où il joue pas beaucoup
attendent du temps reste le plus la
pression
mais parce que c'est difficile mais il a
quand même
un petit stade qui vaut pour lui ça
s'efface et ouverture s'était pas ils
piquent et pas n'importe quoi
souvent du mal à comprendre l'argument
de certains mancha dois me joue parce
qu'ils aiment le jeu mais en fait
ils aiment le jeu forcément jouer des
parties en jeu pendant huit heures c'est
en fait c'est quand même de trucs
différents
et souvent ça se voit après dans les
parties ou quoi ou comme a fait rapporté
plus dutil tous à saint louis je suis
pas à google apps à parler français quoi
c'est la phrase de vlad
c'est vrai
j'ai vu son style de jeu il a l'air de
kiffer vrai mais il est 25 80 quoi enfin
c'est pas la même exigence c'est pas le
même jeu c'est pas la même chose en fait
3g de notre faim celanese et creuse mais
il a trouvé les bravos ding
oui inquiète
ouais bah écoute il va peut-être l'année
un ding
sacrément pénible à défendre avec les
north
mois voire pas fini mais bon il cas où
il pas une position
facile états hôtes payants c'est parti
at on peut les voir
vas-y un
avion parce que en fait
ils viennent de jaunes 40e outils
kawasaki japon très longtemps ils ont
une heure de rajouts et diana coup on a
un petit ait note qui se profile
peut-être
avec ses spasmes pour la france c'est
vrai ça ne se passe pas mal quelques
décisions
étranges de part et d'autre
ça peut même très bien se passer
la difficulté avec les échecs aussi
sceptique tortue n'extériorise pas
physiquement non en fait la chose à
laquelle tu as mal c'est la tête quoi
c'est le cerveau ne peut pas taper un
grand coup dans la balle n'ont pu même
après c'est à dire que
tu as fais pas une fois que tu es tu tu
as joué au tennis ou quoi tu as
peut-être mal aux jambes ça fait mal
partout mais tu peux te détendre
s'amuser au koala aux échecs ça juste la
tête comme un ballon il n'y a plus rien
qui te fait plaisir d'autres plus
qu'assez tard à quai et au pire mais non
tu veux pas mais je dirai rien là qui
font parce que ça c'est que les intrus
clause échec qui va pas fracasser
l'échiquier quoi et puis même en fait ça
tu as tellement pris la tête que ça te
tue le bonheur en fait c'est un peu
particulier
ouais t'as pas le droit de crier t'as
pas le droit de napa laura d'insulter
les joueurs non mais tu as à neuf est
peut-être dû vient enfin tant pis tu
prends une pénalité tu prendrais mille
dix mille dollars de pénalités ou je
sais pas quoi mais bon t'as
gpat a pété un plomb tu l'as fait comme
ça là quand tu pète un plomb
ccg pas au rugby tu peux te battre tu
peux tu cliques sur les épizooties aussi
ouais
bon alors il a dit qu'ils sont fous tu y
ailles au 6e tour preuve
donc alors safiots bah ouais donc tu
fais ce que tu veux mais du coup pas
très bons coups le thème des 3 2 nuls
signé un d'enchères chez duda chez duda
on n'est pas neuf et demi plus grosses
cordes des candidats sous forme un ruban
un record il a survolé le temps l'a déjà
dit mais là jusqu'au bout il aura pas
perdu une partie sans enjeu
bravo magnifique dans la filiation de
larbitre
digne ça a joué juste par curiosité et
quand vous cliquez montgré explique au
46ème rapidement
5 auquel seront courts du rire parti
parti pour durer elle va être sympa
salle à la fin ça va durer encore
on a vu une bonne voire deux bonnes
heures
rapporte juste pour faire finir le tour
j'ai envoyé une pièce un peu dans le
désert tu vas lui aussi il a craqué et
quand on te dire la gestion de tournon
apprendre les petites nul facile pour
personne lendemain pour parer oui mais
bon après voilà qu'on le dit on n'aime
pas on nous dit qu'on est des cons mais
met une nouvelle fois ça se vérifie la
gestion de l'effort important
toujours
et donc on va retourner sur ali reza
j'ai tourné tout les cas mais je
j'ai un copain qui a joué très très haut
niveau au rugby et me disais que quand
il se sentait stressé au premier ballon
il foncé tout droit comme un taré
l'adversaire lui foute 1 pour un tampon
ça le détend des mais oui mais ça
m'étonne pas femme à
la série cadre aux échecs le fait que tu
puisses pas extérioriser physiquement
mais c'est vrai que ça a joué cc c'est
difficile c'est pesant ses assauts en
fait du coup de couches pas forcément
tôt près ce que tu as besoin du soir
noires du monde de faire un repas de
machin tout d'abord un verbe elle est
non mais ben non justement de là tu
trouves pas que c'est que ce serait ce
grand chose que c'était un grand choix
mais bon oui ou non mais t'as besoin
mais tu t'en est de socialiser un peu
tape apparaît de la journée n'a envie de
et pas que
mais oui c'est sûr
et c'est difficile cette classe de
tension dans tout le corps quoi des
fatigues mettez une fatigue physique
mais c'est physique mais je veux dire
t'as pas fait des sports des formulaires
méthane fatigue qui s'installe et du
coup c'est très dur de dormir
tu peux penser encore tu peux encore
réfléchir et c'est pourquoi j'ai fait
des 4 mais bon ça c'est difficile si
t'as pas fait d échec plus ou moins de
haut niveau à arriver juste comme ça je
veux pas te rendre compte en fait
mais du coup fait confiance à fab
normalement quand il vous dit que c'est
un bon ou en mauvais choix il connaît un
petit peu quoi pas une question d'aimer
ou de ne pas aimer en fait c'est une
question que
il a trouvé un fil rouge mais je le
sentais trouvé ça
quelle partie catastrophique des deux
joueurs mais surtout de fabiano mais du
coup ça va bien sur ces professions la
partie et parce que tu peux avoir un
pion à passer quoi
salah est catastrophique wes
bush et son show leur faut des 6es peut
pas défendre à 4
bien joué je pense ça va gagner pour
finir où ça pourrait laisser le bon
souvenir finale quoi ouais et la
lanterne rouge warm up boys avaient
annoncé les deux moins bons joueurs
et workers
le rapport aujourd'hui aussi c'est
pas si pire ou pas quoique caruana a
salu sinon ouais
c'est parti ça tu as du mal à quantifier
le niveau de jeu parce qu'il ya des
périodes où il ya et des moments où il
faut forcément très bien je suis
aujourd'hui au niveau puis tu as des
coups à 1600 1700 quoi
c'est assez étonnant mais moi je vais
vraiment ça sur le compte de la fatigue
et de lassitude un plus sans parler d'un
coup c'était une séquence en fait
c'était un plan c'était tout mauvais
quoi j'ai des fois tu fais une faute de
calcul on comprend ce que tu as fait a
fait un mauvais calcul quoi bon mais
même c'était facile des fois tu
hallucine mais la
décision très étonnante là c'est vrai
que celle là elle me paraît
ta main ne veux pas faire ça en fait
mais j'aime vraiment bien ce que ce que
ce que n'est pas expliqué juste mon
cerveau voulait plus jouer aux échecs
trouve que c'est très animé mais il
faisait pas ça n'est pas donnée défense
oui mais est-ce je passe à chacun sa
manière de faire de la merde après un
fab mais oui si ce cerveau qui ennuie
refuse mais moi j'ai un peu cette
sensation parfois j'en ai parlé mais on
n'en parlait pas plus inquiet reçoit
enfin j'ai cette sensation toi c'est
différent on voit des fois c'est ça
marche pas ça démarre pas en fait ça
veut plus et ça bloque je veux y
démarrer toi faut que tu veuilles
démarrer et ça démarre bailly said bakar
rythme ça va mais bon moi ça démarre et
moi des filles et fils et puis cédée à
l'école mais pourquoi ça refuse
tous différents évidemment
du coup ce truc de refuser je le
comprends très bien genre tu veux à
réfléchir tu es devant mes rêves potes
ça te dit non en fait puisque pour des
titres avait tout le temps que vous
n'êtes pas voir ça quand même oui mais
c'est terrible
mais à son attitude on voyait qu'il ya
un truc qui n'allait pas match en
commentant d'elecam on était là on
voyait que c'était pas normal
du coup ça explique parfaitement les
parties bizarre qu'il a fournis entre le
très bon et le très mauvais c'est ça il
ya en fait il a il a joué cette sixième
partie et après ça a refusé quoi
et tu as ce qui est marrant c'est que
temps et puis en italie où j'ai super
bien joué
en fait quand j'avais un ennemi sur
trois j'arrivais pas à réfléchir et j'ai
commencé à tout clic tempo au hasard
j'ai gagné trois parties d'affilée en
clic et après c'est reparti
gaffeur la main c'est encore joué ouais
mais du coup je réfléchissais plus du
tout et cs avait remis le truc en place
mais parce que j'avais gagné j'aurais eu
car la seine en face en fait ça enfin
briller tabou clic
c'est désespérant face et ça va sentir à
chaque partie mais tu as besoin de jouer
contre un nul quoi mais preuve des
candidats secteur pasqua et oui on en
revient à ce problème là ouais t'as pas
de nul
pour éviter ça c'est vrai que le format
des matchs des verts n'était pas en
forme tu dégages et puis tu te traînes
pâte à peine pendant quatorze parties
s'étaient arrive ça
ça peut être bien ou un coeur tout un
truc venir
enfin qui dit j'ai déjà ressenti ça or
échec c'est horrible il n'y a rien à
faire notre ressource et le cerveau
ouais tu peux c'est un leurre de micro
burn out chez pas comment dire quoi mais
tu
as d'où l'importance de gérer ses forces
et de pas s'entêter
caruana il s'est complètement écroulé
sur courant alternatif depuis plusieurs
années maintenant caruana il a fait un 0
5 / 4
il perd encore la [ __ ] la phase retour
puis en jouant quand même là par exemple
aujourd'hui une américaine c'est
calamiteux c'est catastrophique ouais
nan mais s est depuis 2008 il joue plus
à son niveau de jeu il a atteint son pic
à ce moment là je me permets un fail est
numéro 1 mondial il fait
rien à dire et depuis il a implosé plus
pareil
il lâche pas complètement la faire et
puis il trouve une petite motif pour
s'arracher comme un grand prix ensuite
on va te choper des qualifs quand même
quoi il est quand même là mais en étant
moins bon que ce qu'il a été in haifa
revenir à ce qu'il a fait mais je crois
qu'il travaille un peu moins qu'avant on
avait dit
il a tout donné qu'il a trouvé une
copine mais sur un match à la tête il a
un chien
fois qu'il a un chien
en fait je veux que tu as ton chien
machin étouffante et heureux je te
regarde et
vise un petit chat est un chat un chien
mais c'est vrai qu'une fois que tu as
ton chien
un peu
hier chez toi tu passe la tondeuse
les trucs américain quoi ta la ville de
rêve en fait
[Musique]
on se sent gober les uns après les
autres partis de pac-man
voilà bouffard h quatre ans voilà calmes
basescu est arrivé
wesley à un chat dino main avec ses
poils longs et tous
les vents un chien
je sais plus oui mais les montres et
noir à tête avec ton chien tva fin
j'ai pas
je suis pas
en aquarium
dans lequel ils nagent
de haut niveau qui a une famille riche
dans le top10 ring et rock mais bon ceux
qui sont candidats
d'instruction aux candidats ce qui en un
qui a des enfants d'être rapport mais je
suis pas sûr je pense qu
il est marié rapporte mais
rajab bof je crois manente banon
ils sont jeunes aussi vous voit plus
loin
cardrona dépôt c'est sûr que non les ont
30 ans 35 ans
ouais après oui bon vivre où les jeunes
d'où des jeunes
ils ont dans mais oui ils ont pas
forcément dit famille côté ça va c'est
pour l'énergie du temps moins de temps
pour centrer magnus oui c'est vrai que
c'est un point commun
ce que ça pourrait être moitié-moitié
l'a vu l'âge des participants
on a déjà gagné des bombes étonnant
partie catastrophique de richard et
bravo à raj ares 1 qui va venir terminer
sur le podium sur le podium du tournoi
extraordinaire un fab très belle fin de
parcours laissez chauffer le temps doit
durer 28 ronde
attention et c'est fou quand même ce
résultat d' radja ouais alors qu'on lui
disait ya pas moyen radja il dit sicilia
moyens
bravo à lui en tout cas félicitations
bon résultat on n'y croyait pas et on a
eu tort
hikaru nakamura peut-être en train de
laisser passer à la deuxième place
du coup qui redonne du leverage un cap
c'est dans ces négociations ah que oui
c'est vrai que 6 cars ou terminer
deuxième il n'était pas bien magnus on
va on va remettre pour le moment la
partie de
d'ali reza qui a l'air complètement
gagnant incroyable cette partie quand
même je suis étonné du niveau de jeu
brésilien oui ça va donner encore de
l'eau au moulin cramique
ses tantes et que le moulin soit encore
opérationnel
atteint un meilleur des partages on
pense que naka mais on verra ça à la fin
je sais pas ce que ça le départage fait
que c'est le seul enberg mais bon de
façon à la troisième place vous pourrez
rien famille grosz juste pour dire
qu'ils aient une médaille
camille qui ragent non-stop mais cram
miqueu
président app on a déjà dit il n'a pas
trop tard dans le fond mais il ya des
trucs là il doit pas faire
honte à raismes et mais il n'a pas tout
pas forcément tort à 200% quoi
gradins plus un c'est beau à la surtout
qu'il était à moins de trois parties et
les nuls pour finir donc un peu dans le
style crainte car yakine esque ouais
mais lui en russie va bien j'ai reçu son
tour oui il fallait faire du neuf nuls
il a essayé de faire les petites nul
rapide puis puis quand il fallait
cueillir les points parce qu'on
sacrifiait des pièces il a fait il a
fait une très bonne partie quand il a
battu na ka très solide très propre et
sans votre victoire kondi agba ding du
jeu qu'on sait pas ce qu'il a fait en
fait que cette partie mais en tout cas
il a été là pour en profiter
et toi quand on reparle de gestion de
tournoi cette première partie déjà à
vlad qui était un peu critique quand sir
ou déjà joué le gain au jeu tout est là
nul un stand contre raj à s'embarquer
dans une partie de six heures et blagues
qui disait null null null rapide rentrer
dans la chambre d'hôtel on va dormir là
n ont finalement ça a été payée plus
tard dans le tournoi
lisez là nul ça ne nous fait pas peur
gamers mais bon c'est vrai que c'est pas
très beau suis affecté mais bon c'est la
vie c'est la règle en fait tout va bien
moi je l'aurais pas fait oui mais enfin
jarry la loi defferre il fait enfin n'ya
pas de pataquès est de jouer en tournoi
il ya des règles non mais bien sûr enfin
gea l'autre a pas triché
mais
une allusion
à toutes les histoires avec topaloff ah
oui non ou m'impose j'ai pas d'allusion
ce jusque
café kaymer baïla il a joué la pendule
contre cramique il l'a fait tout ça sur
internet en trois minutes et pas de rage
minutes andy l'une est ok pas de rajouts
et en fait
g nickel à une tour un fou un pion qui
marie les qu'une tour oui archi gagnant
et jaar km heure il a plus que quelques
secondes krasniqi l'enap plus ou moins
20 km/heure primove tous crins dit qu il
tombe quoi est elle dit que
de la merde on fait ça que c'est pas
respectueux
c'est pas faux enfin moi je suis
d'accord mais en même temps il a l'aura
de le faire étape et t'as pas d'état pas
besoin en fait de t'énerver à faire un
communiqué enfin juste une joue plus bas
qu'en regardant aller title pourtant
c'est mon métier bah je peux plus les
jouets sama
suite il te profondément des title pour
les problèmes qu'on connaît même s'il
existe moins qu'avant mais justin
mathilde profondément tu le joues puma
et des chars des postes on fout en fait
il pourrait ne pas faire de potes et lui
il en pense qu'ils pensent et ils disent
qu'il a raison de penser ça mais juste
une fille voilà s'appuie tout ce qu'il
te plaît jarque bas qu'il essayait les
10 +0 là le week-end ce que craint minga
je brûle en a fait 3 il a compris merci
au revoir enfin et ça va pas plus loin
puis des fois y'a jules qui en clic
quelques-uns j'ai vu que maxime joue
aussi de temps en temps mais cette fois
tu es fait pas toutes les semaines ça
fait un an qu'on tente c'est que les
mecs font tomber tu cliques et puis
enfin je vois pas où est le problème en
fait mais après nous aussi on préfère
que ce soit 10 + 1 et on comprend pas la
cadence va s'arranger car ou mais de
ricard ou l'a dit les quatre ans c'était
très important
mais ça arrange hikaru c'est tant mieux
pour lui bras fin à tant mieux mais
j'ai juste eu joua les fautes a envie de
jouer et puis tu sais que ça fait tomber
puis super anton menth en piste mais je
vois pas le problème c'est les règles
ses fins bon
il s'inscrit connaît les règles c'est
que ces 10 +0 ici que c'est internet et
il sait que tout le monde flag donc au
bout d'un moment
ça ne sort un communiqué de presse parce
qu'il ya un gamin de 16 ans qui t'a fait
tomber normes et bon
genre une raison dans le fond c'est de
la merde vers ça mais en fait juste
c'est pas grave ça temps on s'en fout
mais bon comme je dis moi j'aurais pas
faire
oui mais bon c'est lui l'a fait et tant
mieux
il s'est pris pour kamski le frère au
king john bah oui m'enfin moi par ambre
kamski je n'ai pas fait tomber la partie
d'après ils essayent de me faire tomber
non mais je me rappelle lui et non non
c'est trop mais j'ai roquette n'a rien
fait le mec enfin je prends l'exemple de
kamski quoi ces packs rami et le mec et
je suis une légende ne pas me faire
tomber bon du coup moi j'ai pas fait
parce que je le pense aussi faim moi
c'était près c'était avant et la partie
d'après ils peuvent faire tomber il fait
tout pour me flag non mais j'ai en fait
c'est ok t'es une légende mais
enfin va te faire [ __ ] en fait donc tu
as des fois ils sont aussi un peu
spéciaux servait bon toi si tu ne peux
pas les mois je peux oui bon ben ok ça
va aller cinq minutes quand même
donc on peut se voudra que chacun voit
midi à sa porte
qui vont fuser dire que c'est hikaru qui
a lancé cette mode de faire tomber tout
le monde non mais réellement je sais pas
non mais vraiment vraiment les gens le
faisait - après puis caroux semiha
stream à faire ça tout le temps dans
tous ses lives du coup tout le monde
s'est mis à le faire un bavoir ouais
c'est bien exemple certains sont mis à
le faire puis ça fait un joueur de
boules de neige et même moi qui le
faisait pas avant dans cette sphère
bariolés stream il ya trois ans je le
faisais moi où il ya quatre ans puis
vont maintenant tout le monde le fait
mais moi si vous faites tomber enfin
mêmes bas qui s'y est mis même pas qui
fait tomber 29 leur âne à [ __ ] alors
que tu connais pas qui il s'entraîne en
bonus vous faites tomber je vais tomber
aussi se regarde toi aussi tu es tombé
donc j'aimerais ça avoir d'effet boule
de neige tout le monde le fait donc
c'est pas tout ça mais normal alors oui
c'est quasi chronique c'est que bon
c'est ça nouveau normal ça m'intéresse
pas quoi
et caro était ou de se rendre sa face à
riscle en scène mais complètement elle
est carrément fait supprimer la vidéo et
voulait faire supprimer sa chaîne il
avait tenté de faire subir c'est comme
l'histoire en fait c'est en scène qui le
fait tomber ou un truc comme ça ouais
bon ok du coup il
prend les extraits de la vidéo de naka
il la met sur sa chaîne en effet tombée
nein carouge fort que lui en violet et
il met la vidéo sur sa chaîne et la
paroisse droits d'image vincent valade
avoir des images dont kylie il lui
envoie un copyright raikes qui est enfin
tu vois je sais pas c'est le truc qui se
fait mais
enfin c'est un des pires trucs que tu
peux faire dans le milieu de youtube
enfin ça se fait tellement pas c'est je
sais pas comment dire c'est j'ai même
pas de comparaison dans le monde des
échecs de ce que ça pourrait être mais
c'est enfin c'est pas que c'est horrible
c'est j'ai même pas le mot en fait très
mal à la chaîne sur un truc que c'est
pas grand chose battus c'est bien peu et
fermer une chaîne alors que toi tu
utilise aussi des morceaux de phare à
mons et j'ai même pas le mot fin si j'ai
des maux pour mais voilà c'est juste que
mes faux c'est graffin et du coup et
caribou il ne mais ce n'est pas moi qui
ai pris cette décision c'est mon manager
mme très grave du coup il a viré son
manager bon alors que l'on et a du coup
ça s'arrange aimé
voilà c'est très grave
ce serait un peu comme si aux échecs je
faisais exprès de mettre un téléphone
dans ta poche quand tu vas jouer et j'ai
bien regardé c'est un tricheur il avait
des goûts mais c'est pour écrire et me
fait vraiment mal j'aime ce à quoi pour
faire croire que 15 joueurs trichent
tout genre de trucs
mais ça c'était enfin je sais pas il ya
quelqu'un qui ne laisse pas à moi juste
c'est un v1 fins et il n'y a pas de
c'est pas ça pas partir sur internet en
mode à machin un tel avenant
il n'y a pas de fin enfin vc10 v1 et ça
termine mais
non ça c'est vraiment très gras fins
j'ai pas léger pas les mots pour les
gens qui font ça mais peu importe
mais mais du coup il alors qu'il fait ça
toute la longueur de journée j'ai
l'impression que ces joueurs de haut
niveau leur crâne michael fincke rami
que j'ai pas d'exemples précis mais je
vais ensemble ces joueurs de haut niveau
enfin quand tu leur fond ce qui te font
en fait c'est très grave tout d'un coup
enfin ça se fait vraiment pas mais bon
l'histoire s'était soldée finalement
avec une seule victime collatérale qui
était son manager qui s'est fait virer
je leur ai demandé
mais pas le choix quoi
et qu'il avait fait des dons à hauteur
tête de cinquante ou soixante mille
euros contre lui
mais bon peut-être que je sais pas eu un
arrangement qui a été trouvé et c'est à
ce moment là qu'ils car on a perdu
énormément de sape sur sa chaîne
ok ça se fait tellement pas que mais bon
c'est déjà oublié tu vois comme tout
quoi
lewis avait été très très très très très
mal accueillie par la communauté
a juste fait pas échangé je pense
cheikh
saoud options
2,5 je suis moi je ferai à la rive saint
caprais n'a pas fait parce que
c'était trop blanc ici moi je vais faire
bref 5 mais je passe sa démarche non
mais f4
voilà bah ça
et tu pars là bas
wigan a redit ce qui s'était échauffé
tous y voit bon c'était une grosse
histoire si c'est pas facile mal fini
assez grave en fait mais
disons ça aurait pu être
la rivière dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
les gens oublient vraiment tout donc ça
passe mais c'est vrai
il ya des trucs de certains c'est
900 km entre songe quoi ce truc là là là
dans le truck di caro s'est enfin
mais les trucs mille fois plus grave et
ça passe quand même
bien sûr le bout de leurs vins peu et
puis
[Musique]
bel et bien oui en fait j'aime cette
crise exceptionnelle
l'histoire s'est arrangé mais où il y
avait il ya veinards os 10 6 en été mais
les favoris york times jeudi vont
souvent rick hansen
rien il écoute jaunes et deux guerres je
sais pas pourquoi on a émis à discuter
de sa
banque ramener qui disait que ça tombait
je suis pas quoique emphatique à rousset
lui qui faisait flag et des gens est que
ces gens s'inspirer de lui et lui avec
c'est cramé que le coupable des
digressions ses digressions marrante
faible ici peut aujourd'hui faire autour
d'un cas très bas il a fait 0 5 / 4 et
leur période
catastrophique ça va se retourner
mais il va perdre aujourd'hui
oui
c'est bien une femme connaît pas en fait
un germe sont que dès qu'il a arrêté de
jouer pour la gagne c'est complètement
désuni quoi ou alors ils apprennent
physique ça fait beaucoup de parties
très longue date carrément le cerveau a
fondu
raconté comme ça donc si tu peut
expédier tu es mon prochain tournoi
ça tiendrait qu'à d'où il y aurait
beaucoup de nuls rapide
mais richie aujourd'hui pareil il eu
l'occasion de faire laver arena
vous connaissez des joueurs de haut
niveau qui a mené au total ont été
dégoûtés ne peuvent plus touché un
échiquier où suivre les échecs basse
allofs ouais ça la faisait le bon
exemple
après on active et qui peuvent plus
tenir la compétition maé qui peuvent
jouer aux échecs genre les cocoyes ouais
on y joue encore un peu mais
fischer s'est d'ailleurs ça doit être ça
la ddt ouais c'est ça il suit à fond les
échecs il analyse toujours il fait plein
de trucs mais il joue plus en plus du
tout puis 6,6 en
louant gars aussi ouais mais avant il
est où oui
bah oui fans aussi un peu plus ou moins
ça arrive assez souvent fait
la somme il adore les échecs en devient
il content de partager
c'est un érudit incroyable du jeu ou
quoi mais l'attention des parties de
tourner ça s'intéressent plus quoi bon
tu peux aimer les échecs mais palette
infligé cinq mois derrière mais toi
bientôt
ouais enfin un peu
bas toi un peu bourré déjà je suis je
bien j'ai bien freiner le
saas est commun en fait je ris et qu'on
les connaît moins vu qu'ils ont arrêtés
oui
mais qu'est ce l'été quand les 41 42 ans
il arrive plutôt quand même ray et est
toujours numéro 1 mondiale est la règle
krasniqi arrêté à 40 quelque chose
gauthier mais voilà
quand même beaucoup et on parle de gens
connus après tout les gens qui auraient
pu devenir pro et qui n'ont pas voulu et
on a aussi beaucoup bête à neuilly par
exemple comme ça c'est un bon talent
indien 26 ckac très jeune très jeune un
des records tri que c'était de grands
maîtres puis parti aux états unis et
fait des études auraient écrit les
livres un peu d'échecs de sureau 4 ou
quoi il partage son répertoire c'est
bien c'est un peu le format que tu aimes
pas mais
mais ok il fait un peu
il joue plus
en mettant à plat en fait aussi tous
ceux qui sont allés faire des études aux
états unis il y en a plein et tubes
labadie peuvent venir y en a plein des
comme ça
ni unique dans les gros talent
manar audit ce qui en vrai alors il joue
de temps en temps mais en fait il avait
stoppé les échecs très tôt aussi mal
mais oui en a il y en a beaucoup il y en
a vraiment beaucoup
millar fait de grosses sessions bah oui
mais tu le vois souvent joue en partie
longue marron enfin il est plutôt sur
mon profil vous le profil que pourrait
devenir l'adjoint la ville voudrait
jouer le match contre krikor mais va pas
jouer en partie longue
mais juste là je pense qu'ils commencent
à comprendre c'est être pas con de juste
blitz est juste s'envoyer vraiment chez
les longues et faire que des blitz en
fait
un art où il joue très peu à la longue
je l'aï croisé une fois un tournant en
corse le porticcio là
mais il jouait pas enfin darwin
nadia touabti championnats des états
unis un petit machin mais pour viol vers
20h30 partie par an grand messe
j'avais il a arrêté aussi
en scène aussi c'est vrai qu'il a quasi
arrêté
donc ouais non il ya beaucoup de gens
qui arrêtent parce que ça allait souvent
revanche je connais peu de gens qui
arrêtent les rapides et les blitz a
contrario
d'ailleurs même chronique karaté karaté
et puis les revenus engrangés ce tour et
lui faire deux très peu de gens qui
arrêtent le rapide et le beats
s'étonnant quand même
de permettre les toits dans le truc
auquel tout le monde aime jouer
non mais c'est vannes à acheter aussi
l'arrêter mais il joue aussi en blitz
bon après lui l'a jamais été
jouer au
parc c'est marrant que beats plaisir les
gens font
parce qu'ils préfèrent streamé mais non
ne pas donner côté streamer en fait negi
la page et aux iphone stream pas
ici la légion qui juste rime pas il y en
a qui strient mais peu importe c'est le
même profil il faut autre chose tu veux
stream est sur autre chose je vais faire
des études c'est autre chose tu veux
gérer un business autre chose
6 - fiq du genre à vis des beats en fait
c'est pour ça que les vieux continue à
jouer dans ces cadences et non en
longues voilà la plupart des gens
compacité ils sont pas vieux série lé
préfet mais de façon peu importe c'est
ce que j'ai déjà dit ça dans le stream
mais moi le redire c'était pas
aujourd'hui donc c'est que si jamais tu
vas te faire un repas chez un ami le
dimanche que didier ans une petite
partie vais pas vous mettre six heures
chacun la pendule 1 vous avez joué ça a
duré une heure deux heures max vous
allez faire des blitz si vous êtes vous
et du matériel et machin ou du 20
minutes maxi savait pas où [ __ ] trois
heures chacun certains je vous mets pas
plus que huawei donc en fait juste c'est
que de base c'est la cadence tout envie
de jouer c'est envie de jouer alors que
si on fait un tennis on peut jouer en
deux sets gagnants
comme on complète en fait
j'étais catalogué voilà on met 30
minutes chacun voilà donc tu peux faire
des mises je fais 30000 genre vingt ans
après à chacun fait ce qu'il veut fait
mais ça pour dire que
c'est pas vous mettre trois heures
chacun et un rajout d'une heure au 40e
coup est encore un rajout 60e vous avez
juste jamais faire ce à quoi donc quand
tu joues plus que tu as envie de te
détendre je faire quelques parties pour
le plaisir battue va faire le format que
tu faisais quand tu veux je te faire
plaisir voilà
c'est vraiment et c'est vraiment un des
seuls sports pro je vois qu'il ya une si
grande différence entre la pratique
amateur plaisir et compétition ce qu'on
va tennis ouais enfin nous tue avec la
ddt quand on a joué on n'avait pas trop
de temps on avait 58 on a fait un set
quand même en ce jeu gagnant et si on
avait eu deux heures devant nous on
aurait fait deux sets gagnants
évidemment
mais même nous si on va jouer demain et
qu'on voulait jouer un match on ferait
ça mais ce serait étonnant de jours un
truc et dans le truck pro qui dure
ah les huit fois plus longtemps j'avais
fait en dix huit sets gagnants
c'est très étonnant en fait
même au foot quoi tu joues tu joues une
heure une heure et demie broadfoot on
est fatigué ou tu le premier individu
touche pas coiffer un truc et ça
ressemble plus que jamais même quand tu
fais des fous de sable ça a duré un
moment
c'est pas une heure et demie mais c'est
peut-être une heure macho
à 36 ans n'a pas aujourd'hui ils
prennent l'avion
le cyclisme mais ces différences parce
que tu es bloqués
comme exemple c'est pas dégeu amené vélo
il sait que tu es pas un jeu en fait
c'est un exploit physique
c'est que le marathon tu vas pas dire un
petit marathon pour le plaisir mais
c'est toujours un petit tu vas te faire
un petit footing cette envie mais et
puis c'est pas dégeu ça et c'est pas
dégeu
deux cents
mats jamais reims tu fais comme ça
c'est beau hein
d'autres peuvent remonter l'alpe d'huez
certains vont essayer
petite pause on peut on peut encore
s'attendre à elle s'attend qu on revient
à tout à l'heure
on joue un mauvais tour
sa clique un sa clique un coup depuis
qu'on est parti je crois ou plus
sa clique qu'est-ce que ça à cliquer sa
clic
clic clic clic clic clic clic et pas
grand chose en fait
non mais c'est en train de clics c'est
entre un petit qu'une quatrième place
pour hikaru
sans dubitatif bon je comprendre qu'on
gagne en force
ding aussi est juste par curiosité
ok là ça va jouer longtemps ouais
on est parti pour un marathon fab we are
partie de forums marathon fab
c'était en anglais
bishop siffler
[Musique]
king night magic jack king white lies
file john
bishop
différents
check
suis par exemple en défaut mais bien
hifive tech de douceur
et en présente move
maintenant il me faut peut-être
au texas et valdez
et oui fab eliès fab
de candidats en othe quoique thiès
finished but de
souley
happiness happy days of course
tout
se passe
comme si
votre boss manager comme sa
difficulté difficulté position for food
américaine player practices
il thinking
tournament mine de rien à celle de
fresnes
de chat
mine de rien
hikaru avec les pièces noires
c'est le french
wendy peau douce jacques attitude finito
m et byzantine 6 mai buisson may find
move pingdom hellip on chip taxi
feinberg
fff style good movie comme thinking
nature croyait 3 to play hilux
disappointed with playfish force de
fabien
est hostile containing pour le first
lady
gaga
looking at the bottom
turn a pu faire ça non looking like
phaneuf de saint-etienne chine yu na
li a récidivé seniors france rinne one
ring les verts les verts ag s'est rasé
c'est
à le faire car les bleus you know allez
les bleus allez les bleus
est ce les bleus dans baby à l'aise
l'iphone 5 à l'aise à l'aise les bleus
à l'aise l'hiver à l'aise les bleus
[Musique]
bien
sûr
ce n'est pas fini
beaucoup plus intéressant que je
commente
notre intensité dans le
tout est très intéressant à tunis
un écart qui pourrait terminer 4e une
grande déception pour lui forcément qui
se rêvait tant que challenger il faudra
revenir pour hikaru qui a réalisé un
beau tournoi mais de passe il aura
peut-être raté l'occasion dans sa partie
contre n'est pas d'amour il a su ça et
défaite contre hadja qui a pas été une
bonne partie de sa part mais il a bien
perdu après mais il a un peu raté
l'ouverture
il a senti en plus que ça c'est quand il
a raté ça que c'était un raté un drap
tournant
celui avec les normes on ouvre on peut
dire ça surtout l'activité des pièces et
le pion g7 qui est très faible le
chipset peut pas bouger c'est compliqué
le pion racisme un petit tour à sept ça
peut vite faire mal tant pis on veut
passer chez les blancs donc t'as pas mal
d'atouts quoi un peu floue et de partout
phocéen
on
sumbe de ce vote seul coup moi j'aurais
peut-être fait pour histoire d'accrocher
sa
joie que l'ordi défense
mais juste arranger six attaques ça et
je bouge
qualifie françois rossi voulait chercher
ça défonce en fait
on doit aussi c'est impossible ok c'est
un
bon fou des 4 pourquoi pas
après les mêmes manoeuvres tactiques
juste aura à 18h54 a l'air fort
en fait un vrai support bay 5-1 douceur
ici quoi ouais tout et je lui servant
bien en fait
beaucoup de victoires en drapant dans
ses candidats je sais pas je peux fait
les stats mais ça s'est souvent fait que
les joueurs blanc essaie de trop forcer
donne une chance
c'est pas si surprenant que ça en fait
on se répète mais d'où la force donné
pour qui va jamais rien forcer avec les
blancs ou
nuls ne m'intéresse pas du tout
c'est simple il a battu il a bâti son
tournoi en battant les trois derniers
qualifiés ou 2 0 il a battu rapporte un
an et demi il a battu d'houdain amis
et tous les autres il a fait daniel
harding voilà
mais le gros du score a été fait là bas
contre les warm up ouais
bon ce final qui devrait être gagnante
mais c'est pas encore fait il va falloir
aller chasser cette tour de la cades qui
soit une case blanche donc avait ramené
le
royaume pour rien mais on va se
concentrer sur l'a7 geôles a priori
sur les douceurs
je crois que c'est le jour où je suis le
plus
il faisait chaud aujourd'hui le niveau
d'humidité
très haut
on attend un petit peu sud-asiatique
d'être au chaud pour commander
aujourd'hui fab
fodé 2
on devrait pouvoir prendre un truc tout
petit jeu sera 6
je suis pas mal en prenant ainsi si tu
peux contournée par là bas
du coup c'est clair ce qu'il doit faire
les change tout et de défense ouais
il le fait à duda il le fait là
mathieu qui m'écrit
décidé très content du très bon repos il
veut qu'on lui envoie nos analyses quand
même revenus à leur ai écrit ses veaux
issus on va faire on va faire face de
plus à toi d'ailleurs c'est toi qui as
to
be mesure digne je sais pas
je sais pas du tout
elle va finir non quartier g6 et poussé
l'an
il a pris la 6
abstiens toi aussi un peu
coulissant terminé il peut attaquer ça
faire des choses
qui arrive juste s'il abandonne pas
l'amener puisque c'est la désillusion
quoi c'était sont enfin
c'est quand même un objectif
un échec je pense pour que le roi m'a
dérangé 4 on va se mettre dans les
fourchettes
mais bravo d'hinguain un petit orage et
de tranquillo
sympa ouais une idée aujourd'hui
je voudrais au cas où mais je sais pas
ce que ludwig va mettre
cette partie c'est au cas où qu'enfin
se dire d'autre quant à une autre idée
de titres au cas où au cas où c'est au
cas où magna au cas où alors fait cette
partie on mais aucun au cas où tu
bats ces genres pour verser une partie
de merde mais 20 déguisant l'enjeu mais
qui sait au cas où enfin un peu en semi
péjoratif quoi
il joue un peu au dessus et souvent par
l'inertie
est un peu devant la qui souffle je sais
bien
mais en fait c'est mon sens que si fait
tour à 7 c'est quasi la même position
que tout à l'heure mais mon camion il
manque un pion et voilà il est vissé 1
je pense tous les goûts son fils ado
peut être trop mal
17 ans fait ça oui c'est bien ça c'est
bien tu empêches keyyo cinq mâts par
principe je serai toujours à sept tours
bessette enfin après je dis ça mais
c'est aux beats après en partie chez pas
deuxième radja troisième donc sert que
si magnus et ding refuse de jouer le
match championnat du monde radja pour
radhia pour et ouais si radja refuse
à katrina cas et si naka refuse or là on
va dépendre des résultats entre
phobie non ce serait famille quand même
famille et après siph a dit refuser que
firent ouja gagne 100 000 et a pressé le
warm up boys ah ouais donc ça joue quand
même pas pour rien la partie firoud déjà
caruana attention s'il ya oui il ya
vingt-huit refus peut-être qu'à un
moment à aa je me glisse attention fab
c'est aussi douceur g-five
ami veut mettre les indous heures en
justice
ce film est un jouisseur en d4
pour ne pas gagner cette finale bat ça
m'étonnerait pas spécialement non plus
hein
je pense qu'il va gagner mais bon bah
c'est pas 100% voilà mais il vient pas
de se bloquer passé si tu te prends le
chemin du roy en fait qu'environ
mais bon le vent lui même et c'est
justement ces quatre mois je sais pas je
cherche je comprends tu rendras plus
rien à [ __ ] cette partie là de je veux
pas savoir aminé
non mais après on s'est passé comme ça
enfin si crime il te dit ces niveaux
2002 il a raison mais c'est même pas en
fait c'est même pas niveau thème de je
sais je les joue le une passe à quoi
genre rondins vianney là qui me fait
tout raid 5 tu vois pas apte à des coûts
quoi
avec ses 6 et carabines et la raison
robin side
mais ça sert à rien fait mise à part tu
bloques et passage le passage mais après
on va voir
ça peu
habile peut enlever à tour deux à quatre
peut-être en gras
femme il quitte mentalement bah ouais
mais faut dire
que non tu n'es pas heureux d'analysé
des échecs fabien
ça rend fou en fait au bout d'un moment
ça rend fou de commenter
leurs besoins et on a déjà vu des
mauvaises parties dans le tournoi mais
surtout un joueur qui faisait cadeau
bien les deux qui se tient prend les
cadeaux mais non sans façon
ah ouais ça j'avais pas trop
subsisteront de jeter pas travailler
mais c'était
c'était violent aussi un mail à
aujourd'hui
mais je t'assure que rapporte chirurgien
d'un match
décerné la partie de plomb à deux
candidats je pense à l'alcool oui mais
les pires mais l israël a plus d'enjeu
lalaude c'est la deuxième séance est
dans ton ton les deux c'était ou l'adil
halluciné
final 40 affiche à l'équilibré par un
docteur pour ya quand même un pion de
plus ceux achetés catalan attention et
un douceur en plus
d'houdain rapporte aussi la première le
malaise j'ai rarement vu une aussi
mauvaise partie de la porte qu'est-ce
que c'est un thème sicilienne c'était
gagnant au blanc après huit coups
il a fait n'importe quoi
l'ouvragé pas du tout
mais la partie allait
si je te montre c'est
avoir envie quoi
on va être ap
mauvais coup quoi
ouais c'était qu'elle rompe je peux
trouver sur la ronde 1 mais je vais la
trouver bon d'accord je suivais pas le
tandem et la partie allait
donc du coup je vais avoir atteint d'or
à portivy nul
matière je les lave en toi je pense
à mes oui mais d'accord enfin choix je
l'avais vu
j'en fais fiat gérardmer
soupçonnons
wii se structurent écrasante
même finir par être mal en fait la
troupe stress oui je sais mais fait grc
apparemment catastrophique ouais mais ça
aurait pu être aussi mauvais 1 s'est
prononcé sur gagner aujourd'hui du coup
de passe devant moi même
même acabit
j'ai droit au cas où il aurait mangé
vite